So welcome to SmartList everybody. I hope you have a full charge on your iPod. Do people still use iPods? No. I don't think so. I think they just use... Is that what they listen to us on? Their phones. Okay, boomer. What is... is boomer what ages are Boomers? 1946 to 64.
欢迎收听 SmartList。希望你们的 iPod 还有电。现在还有人用 iPod 吗？没有。我不觉得。我觉得他们只用……我们就是通过这个被收听的吗？他们的手机。好吧，老登。什么是……老登是哪个年龄段的人？1946 年到 64 年。
I just looked it up today. Truly? Truly. Wow. What's a Zier? Us. That's us. No, we're Gen X, man.
我今天刚查过。真的吗？真的。哇。什么是 Z 世代？我们。那就是我们。不，我们是 X 世代，老兄。
Oh, we're X. Sorry. What are the ages of X? Gen X is like 19... Well, sorry. We keeping you up? You know we're rolling, bro. 1960...
哦，我们是 X 世代。抱歉。X 世代的年龄是多少？X 世代大约是 19……好吧，抱歉。我们吵醒你了吗？你知道我们在录节目，老兄。1960……
Are we rolling right now? Yeah, we're cold opening the shit out of this right now. Is this an all-new Smartless? Alright, welcome to Smartless. Oh, yeah. Well. Yes. Well, Will. Today's Will's guest.
我们现在在录吗？对，我们现在正在进行极其随意的冷开场。这是一期全新的 Smartless 吗？好吧，欢迎来到 Smartless。哦，是的。好吧。是的。好吧，威尔。今天威尔的嘉宾是。
It is. Yeah. It is. How are you feeling about your guest today, Will? I'm feeling very good about my guest. Yeah. Well, because, I mean, I don't want to get into it too quickly, but because it's somebody that we all know, so.
是的。对。是的。威尔，你对今天的嘉宾有什么感觉？我对我的嘉宾感觉非常好。对。嗯，因为，我的意思是，我不想太快切入正题，但因为这是我们都认识的人，所以。
You'd think I would have a preference as to what I would do. I would have a preference as to what I would do. I'm feeling very good about my guest. Yeah. Well, because, I mean, I don't want to get into it too quickly, but because it's somebody that we all know, so... You'd think I would have a preference as to, you know, either your guests or Sean's guests by now, like who ends up hosting better guests. Do you guys have a preference on, like... I think it's pretty random, right?
你以为我对我要做的事会有所偏好。我对我要做的事会有所偏好。我对我的嘉宾感觉非常好。对。嗯，因为，我的意思是，我不想太快切入正题，但因为这是我们都认识的人，所以……你本以为我对……你知道的，无论是你的嘉宾还是肖恩的嘉宾，到现在都会有所偏好，比如谁最后请到的嘉宾更好。你们对……比如有什么偏好吗？我觉得挺随机的，对吧？
Like, who... A lot of times we bring people on that we all know. Yeah. And then sometimes it's a lot of times it's people none of us know and sometimes we... Sometimes it's in the middle. And sometimes it's right in the middle. And sometimes...
比如，谁……很多时候我们请来的都是我们认识的人。对。然后有时，很多时候是我们都不认识的人，有时我们……有时是居中的。有时恰好居中。有时……
It's fascinating. But like and sometimes we reach out to guests and then sometimes guests reach out to us and it's just... It's just a great blend you guys. I gotta listen to this. And it's just, it's a great blend, you guys. I gotta listen to this show. This show seems great. Jason, it was good to see you last night.
太迷人了。但就像有时我们会联系嘉宾，有时嘉宾会联系我们，这简直是……这简直是完美的融合，伙计们。我得听听这个。这简直是完美的融合，伙计们。我得听听这个节目。这个节目听起来真棒。杰森，很高兴昨晚见到你。
We all had dinner last night, and we haven't seen you in so long. It was so nice to see you, and the dinner was super fun, and everybody was funny. All giddy all night. I laughed real hard last night. And then, I told you. I'm real hard last night. And then I told you.
我们昨晚一起吃了晚饭，我们已经好久没见你了。见到你真是太好了，晚饭超级开心，每个人都很搞笑。一整晚都兴高采烈。我昨晚笑得好大声。然后，我告诉你。我昨晚笑得好大声。然后我告诉你。
I'm real sweet on that Tig Notaro. She's great. She's so funny. I just love her. Hysterical. Hysterical. I told Will this a couple weeks ago, Jason, I finally saw The Godfather.
我对蒂格·诺塔罗（Tig Notaro）很有好感。她太棒了。她太搞笑了。我简直爱死她了。太爆笑了。太爆笑了。我几周前就告诉威尔了，杰森，我终于看了《教父》。
Oh boy. Yeah. Sean says to me the other day. And it was really good. He goes, hey. Was it good, Sean? I was like, you know what? We watched The Godfather the other day. And it was really good. He goes, hey. Was it good, Sean? You know what, we watched the Godfather the other night.
哦，天哪。是的。肖恩前几天对我说。而且真的很好。他说，嘿。好看吗，肖恩？我说，你知道吗？我们前几天看了《教父》。而且真的很好。他说，嘿。好看吗，肖恩？你知道吗，我们前几天看了《教父》。
It's really good. And I said, oh, did you think everybody was lying? And then I just watched that part two, like two days ago, three days ago. Now they say that part two is better than the first. I don't remember having a feeling either way. Yeah, I think. They're different, they're both excellent. Part two, the Godfather two is excellent as well. Yeah, I think. They're different, they're both excellent.
真的很好。我说，哦，你以为大家都在撒谎吗？然后我大约两天前、三天前刚看了第二部。现在他们说第二部比第一部好看。我不记得当时有什么特别的感觉。对，我想。它们不同，但都很优秀。《教父 2》也非常优秀。对，我想。它们不同，但都很优秀。
Part two, Godfather 2 is excellent as well. Yeah, I kinda had to pause every 10 minutes to be like, Scotty, who's that, who's that, who's that? There's so many characters. You're one of those. They remind me never to watch a movie with you. Okay, never watch a movie. And then number three gets a bad rap,
第二部，《教父 2》也非常优秀。是的，我差不多每 10 分钟就得暂停一次，问：斯科蒂，那是谁，那是谁，那是谁？里面角色太多了。你就是那种人。他们提醒我千万别跟你一起看电影。好吧，绝对不跟你一起看电影。然后第三部评价不太好，
but I don't remember watching number three and going, this is terrible. I think he got a bad rap at the time and then now people as they look back they go like they've had a different. I just found, I just gotta just say, Coppola went back in and recut it recently like in the last five years or so.
但我并不记得看第三部时觉得这太糟糕了。我觉得它当时评价不好，然后现在人们回看时，他们的看法变了。我发现，我只想说，科波拉最近又回去重新剪辑了，大概在过去五年左右。
Oh really? Oh really? Yeah. Open it back up. I don't know if that's true. Yeah, three and a half. Yeah, anyway, check it out if you haven't seen it. Hey yeah, if you haven't seen any of the Godfather films.
哦，真的吗？哦，真的吗？对。重新剪辑了。我不知道是不是真的。对，三个半小时。对，总之，没看过的去看看吧。嘿，对，如果你没看过任何一部《教父》电影的话。
Welcome to Smartless Hot Takes on new films. It's like the time Jason came up to me and said, hey, you know what I watched? Blues Brothers is a really good movie. Yeah, I remember that. The 1980 film. A band was humming the Flashdance song the other day and I go, you know, never seen it.
欢迎收听 Smartless 关于新电影的热辣点评。就像有一次杰森走到我面前说，嘿，你知道我看了什么吗？《福禄双霸天》是一部非常好的电影。对，我记得。1980 年的电影。前几天有个乐队在哼《闪电舞》的歌，我说，你知道吗，我没看过。
She goes, oh, you're such a loser. I really am, there's so many. Remember last night we were talking about At Close Range, which is a good movie, I wanna go back once. Haven't seen it. I haven't seen it. I need to see it. Who's in that?
她说，哦，你真是个失败者。我真的是，有太多了。还记得昨晚我们讨论《近距离》吗，那是一部好电影，我想回顾一下。没看过。我没看过。我得去看看。里面都有谁？
Sean Penn and Chris Walken. Oh yeah, I wanna see that. Yeah, let's see. I never saw Flashdance. You didn't? No. No, that surprises me. What about Ghost? I love Ghost. Sean, I'm surprised you I never saw Flash Dance. You didn't? No. No, that surprises me. What about Ghost?
肖恩·潘和克里斯托弗·沃肯。哦，对，我想看那个。对，让我们看看。我从来没看过《闪电舞》。你没看过？没有。不，这让我很惊讶。那《人鬼情未了》呢？我超爱《人鬼情未了》。肖恩，我很惊讶你……我从来没看过《闪电舞》。你没看过？没有。不，这让我很惊讶。那《人鬼情未了》呢？
I love Ghost. Sean, I'm surprised you haven't seen Flash Dance. I know me too, because I dance. Because you like dancing. And you're flashy. And I'm flashy. All right, this is not for the fucking Regis, Kathy Lee chatter.
我超爱《人鬼情未了》。肖恩，我很惊讶你没看过《闪电舞》。我知道我也是，因为我跳舞。因为你喜欢跳舞。而且你很华丽。而我很华丽。好了，这不是给你们这些扯淡的里吉斯和凯茜·李听的。
What are you talking about? This is the fun part. And so is the guest part. But this is fun too. I know, but I always feel bad for the guests. I gotta sit there and listen to the patter. All right, fine. Well, everybody's got busy lives too.
你在说什么呢？这才是搞笑的部分。嘉宾环节也是。但这部分也很有趣。我知道，但我总是为嘉宾感到难过。我得坐在那儿听这些废话。好吧，好吧。不过每个人生活都很忙。
They're probably sending emails and texts and stuff. You think your guest is sending emails and stuff? Well, I know that our, also put it this way. This is a great segue. Our guest is a very, very busy person. Huh. Yeah, because in addition to being a very sought after actress, she's also a very sought after writer and producer.
他们可能在发邮件、发短信什么的。你觉得你的嘉宾在发邮件什么的吗？好吧，我知道我们的……换个说法。我们的嘉宾是一个非常非常忙的人。哈。对，因为除了是一位炙手可热的女演员，她还是一位炙手可热的编剧和制片人。
Oh, really? Yeah. She has written and produced Emmy nominated stuff. She's produced and written big, huge animated films, like, I don't know, Toy Story 4? Sean? You know, she's acted in, and she's written a new series that she's got coming out. Her new series is called, I think it's called Sunny?
哦，真的吗？对。她写过并制作过获艾美奖提名的作品。她制作并编写过超大型动画电影，比如，我不知道，《玩具总动员 4》？肖恩？你知道的，她演过，她还写了一部即将上映的新剧。她的新剧叫，我想是叫《晴天》吧？
Yeah. That's the worst fucking intro I've ever heard. No, because I'm trying to... Just take a little time to write something down when you write something. No, because I'm trying to disguise who it is. You wrote it. You're doing a great job. Because as soon as I say what you know her from, you're gonna know who it is. Let's have it.
对。这是我听过最操蛋的开场白了。不，因为我在试图……写东西的时候花点时间写。不，因为我在试图掩饰她是谁。你写的。你做得太棒了。因为只要我一说出你从哪里认识她，你就会知道她是谁了。说吧。
Because you know her really well, because you know her also very well from things like The Office, and Parks and Rec, and Boston Public, and Freezing... It's an AVV. Pollard? No, it's Rashida Jha! Rashida! Rashida, did you know you were coming out when I saw you last week, two weeks ago? I did.
因为你非常了解她，因为你也从《办公室》、《公园与游憩》、《波士顿法律》和《冰冻……》等作品中非常了解她……是个 AVV。波拉德吗？不，是拉什达·琼斯！拉什达！拉什达，我上周、两周前见你的时候，你知道你要来上节目吗？我知道。
And I don't listen to your show, so I didn't know it was a surprise. I'm really glad I didn't say anything. Okay. Wow. It's happened so many times. I don't even know why we continue the whole structure rate
而且我不听你们的节目，所以我不知道这是一个惊喜。我真高兴我什么都没说。好吧。哇。这种情况发生过太多次了。我甚至不知道我们为什么还要继续整个结构。
Yeah, look at your pink headphones. I know she's got some real headphones My dad's JBL really you rocks a pink headphone. No, this is it's like his oh Oh, really? What's it? Yeah, it's JBL, but it's like his it's like the queue Oh really? What's it called? It's JBL, but it's like the Q. We're happy to do some personal experience if you want to send some of those our way. You got it. By the way, for my sister Tracy,
对，看看你的粉色耳机。我知道她有一些真正的耳机。我爸爸的 JBL，真的吗？你戴着粉色耳机。不，这……这就像他的……哦。哦，真的吗？是什么？对，是 JBL，但就像他的……就像 Q。哦，真的吗？叫什么？是 JBL，但就像 Q。如果你想给我们寄一些，我们很乐意做个人体验。给你。顺便说一句，致我的妹妹特雷シー，
your dad is Quincy Jones. Please continue. Okay. Yes Tracy. That's also if you're not a listener of the. I heard about that. I heard about that. We reference Tracy.
你爸爸是昆西·琼斯。请继续。好的。是的，特雷西。如果你不是这个节目的听众的话，这也是。我听说过这个。我听说过这个。我们提到了特雷西。
Sort of a catch all for those less informed. But there's no shot at Tracy herself. No. She's a very bright, sharp Wisconsinian. She's representing the people. Yeah, she's happy to do it. Rashida, welcome to Smart List. Where are we finding you in this great booth of yours?
对那些不太了解的人来说算是个统称。但并没有冒犯特雷西本人的意思。没有。她是一个非常聪明的、精明的威斯康星人。她在代表人民发声。对，她很乐意这么做。拉什达，欢迎来到 Smart List。在这个属于你的伟大的录音棚里，我们在哪里能找到你？
Thank you. I'm in my husband's studio. That's a question mark. What does husband do? Why does his husband have a studio? He's a musician. He has a radio show, not a podcast, a radio show. Oh.
谢谢。我在我丈夫的工作室里。这是一个问号。丈夫是做什么的？为什么她丈夫有工作室？他是音乐家。他有一个广播节目，不是播客，是广播节目。哦。
But also a musician. Wait, wait, Jason, do you honestly not know who her husband is? I don't, you know how old I am. I barely know what day husband is? I don't I you know how I know I barely know what day it is I've embarrassed myself hourly. You're kidding. On my kid's life I have no idea who her husband is. Her husband Ezra is singer-songwriter extraordinaire have you ever heard of a band called Vampire Weekend? Oh no way Yes, I didn't know that either. Both met him.
但也是个音乐家。等等，等等，杰森，你真的不知道她丈夫是谁吗？我不知道，你知道我多大岁数。我几乎不知道丈夫是……我不知道，你知道我知道吗，我几乎不知道今天是星期几，我每小时都在出洋相。你在开玩笑吧。我以我孩子的生命发誓，我不知道她丈夫是谁。她丈夫埃兹拉是杰出的创作型歌手，你听说过吸血鬼周末这个乐队吗？哦，不会吧。是的，我以前也不知道。都见过他。
Oh, that's right. But he didn't announce his job. He didn't give you his bio. Right. He didn't lead with that. It's like when people come up to you and they go, oh, you're an actor, what are you in? Yeah.
哦，对。但他没有宣称自己的职业。他没有给你他的简历。没错。他没有以此开场。就像人们走到你面前说，哦，你是个演员，你演过什么？对。
Do you want me to start listing you? Well, by the way, still to this day, I assume nobody knows who I am. Nobody knows what I'm, people look at me funny and I'm like, yeah, I know, I look like that guy you went to school with. Right. At this point, really?
你想让我开始给你列举吗？好吧，顺便说一句，直到今天，我依然以为没人知道我是谁。没人知道我是谁，人们奇怪地看着我，我就想，是的，我知道，我看起来就像你上学时认识的那家伙。没错。到了这个时候，真的吗？
Come on. Oh yeah, absolutely. Well, you know why? Because I spent so many years assuming everybody knew who I was and I had a very uncomfortable adjustment. You keep girly. I will never make that mistake again.
拜托。哦，是的，绝对的。好吧，你知道为什么吗？因为我花了那么多年的时间，以为所有人都认识我，我经历了一个非常不舒服的适应期。你继续臭美吧。我再也不会犯那种错误了。
Yeah, now I'm here on this side. Everybody knows you're Justin Bateman. They know that. That's exactly right. I get that once a day. Justin Bateman, big fan. Not that big. Rashida.
是的，现在我在这边。大家都知道你是贾斯汀·贝特曼。他们知道的。完全正确。我一天能遇到一次。贾斯汀·贝特曼，铁粉。没那么夸张。拉什达。
It's so good to see you. Tell me what you're doing like today and what's going on. You know how much I love you. I love you. I love you. What am I doing today? This, I'm doing this.
见到你太好了。告诉我你今天在做什么，最近怎么样。你知道我多爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我今天在做什么？这个，我在做这个。
I'm, I don't, what am I doing today? I'm like prepping for the summer. Oh, how does one prep for the summer? Cleaning the pool? Just like a lot of reps. Got a lot of vegetables? Yeah. No, just like packing.
我……我不知道，我今天在做什么？我好像在为夏天做准备。哦，人怎么为夏天做准备？打扫泳池？就是做很多重复训练。准备了很多蔬菜？对。不，就是打包行李。
Canning booth. Canning booth, of course. Where are you going? Just a lot of, well, I'm doing some press for the show. Oh, yeah. That will mention Sonny. I didn't write it. I'm in it. I'm in it. But I produced it.
罐头作坊。罐头作坊，当然。你要去哪？就是有很多……好吧，我在为这部剧做一些宣传。哦，对。会提到《晴天》。不是我写的。我参演了。我参演了。但我制作了它。
I thought you wrote it, but you produced it. And you produced it. Which is a really cool... The premise is your character moves to Japan, lives in Japan, and her husband dies. Missing. But they were on a plane crash. They're missing, yeah. And the company sends, his company sends you
我以为是你写的，但你制作了。而且你制作了。这真的很酷……大体设定是你的角色搬到日本，住在日本，然后你丈夫死了。失踪了。但他们遭遇了空难。他们失踪了，对。然后公司派了，他的公司派给你
a new personal robot. Yes. Called Sunny. In the future. In the future. Yeah, it's in the future. I had three callbacks for that robot. Did you? Yeah. They said, you know what they said, you know what the note was?
一个新的私人机器人。是的。名叫晴天。在未来。在未来。对，在未来。那个机器人我有三次试镜。是吗？对。他们说，你知道他们说什么吗，你知道评语是什么吗？
Too robotic. Too robotic. I think. Is the only way I tee it up was? Too robotic. Too robotic. Is the only way I tee it up for you, Willie. I know. Well, wait, hang on now. Rashida, you wrote yourself something that puts you in Japan a little bit. I didn't write it, you guys.
太机械了。太机械了。我想。我给你铺垫的方式只有这个吗？太机械了。太机械了。我给你铺垫的方式只有这个吗，威利？我知道。好吧，等等，先别急。拉什达，你自己写了一些把你安排到日本的内容。不是我写的，伙计们。
Let's be very clear. I produced it. But yes, I put myself in Japan. Yes, I lived in Japan. How great was that? It was really great. I know I've never been to a great. Have you been before?
我们要说清楚。我制作的。但没错，我把自己写到日本去了。没错，我在日本住过。那感觉多棒啊？真的很棒。我知道我从来没去过这么棒的地方。你以前去过吗？
Japan is the best. It's the best. I had been there like three or four times for a couple weeks, but I was there for six months. Wow. Wow. Well, now, Kyoto, Tokyo, Osaka. Kyoto and Tokyo. We filmed in both, yeah.
日本是最棒的。它是最棒的。我以前去过那儿三四次，每次呆几周，但这次我在那儿呆了六个月。哇。哇。好吧，现在，京都、东京、大阪。京都和东京。我们在这两个地方都拍了，对。
Wow, that's so cool. Because I hear if you go over there, you gotta have it wired. Like it's a place you need to like have a chaperone or like very good notes or tips or you can get lost there. Yeah, you can, but even getting lost is fun there. It doesn't really matter. There's no bad version of it.
哇，太酷了。因为我听说如果你去那边，你得把一切都安排妥当。就像那是一个你需要有导游，或者有很好的攻略、小费，不然就会迷路的地方。是的，你可以，但在那里迷路也很有趣。其实无所谓。没有不好的版本。
But yes, I was like dialed in because I had like the most amazing PA and like people who really knew the cities. And so like, I just went to the best, coolest restaurants, gardens, temples, onsen. Yeah. So Rashida, you know, I loved Silo so much. I told you when I saw you and I was like,
不过是的，我当时安排得很周到，因为我有一个最棒的制片助理，还有真正了解这座城市的人。所以，我就去了最好、最酷的餐厅、花园、寺庙、温泉。对。所以拉什达，你知道的，我太喜欢《地堡》了。我看到你的时候就告诉你了，我就像，
oh my God, Rashida's in this show that I heard so much about that Io so much, I told you when I saw you, and I was like, oh my God, Rashid is in this show that I heard so much about, that I love so much, and then you died in the first fucking episode. That's, yeah. Spoiler alert. That's how I do it. That's how I do it. I was like, wait, what?
哦，天哪，拉什达演了这部我听说过很多……我太喜欢《地堡》了，我看到你的时候就告诉你了，我就想，哦，天哪，拉什达演了这部我听说过很多、我太喜欢的剧，然后你在第一集就挂了。那是，对。剧透警告。我就是这样。我就是这样。当时我想，等等，什么？
Did that bum you out? Cause that's, every, I- No, that's why I took the job. Okay, okay. Cause it looked like it was locked down. No, it's fun to, it's fun to make people like you and then die. Yeah, if you guys haven't seen Silo, it it's fun. It's fun to it's fun to make people like you and then die Yeah, if you guys haven't seen silo, it's so good James Dean Damn, dude. No way. It's not even 11. Yes
这让你觉得扫兴吗？因为那是，每个……不，这就是我接这份工作的原因。好吧，好吧。因为看起来它已经敲定了。不，把人写得让他们喜欢你然后让他们死掉，这很有趣。是的，如果你们还没看过《地堡》，它真的很好。把人写得让他们喜欢你然后让他们死掉，这很有趣。是的，如果你们还没看过《地堡》，它真的太棒了。詹姆斯·迪恩。天哪，老兄。不会吧。还没到 11 点。是的。
He died by the way, what not too soon by the way, there's no fucking way that's really guess how old he was when he died 23 yeah, was he yeah. Yeah, so yeah, isn't that amazing that he was never older than? 23? Yeah. Was he? That's so crazy. Isn't that amazing that he was never older than 23? I looked at him, I always thought he was like, you know, like, that's a man. I just watched The Giant with him and Ron Hudson and Liz Taylor. Just Giant. More Hot Ticks from Sean.
顺便说一句，他去世了，这算不算太早？顺便说一句，绝对不可能……你猜他死时多大？23 岁。对，是吗？对，所以，难道不令人惊叹吗，他永远没活过……23 岁？对。是吗？太疯狂了。难道不令人惊叹吗，他永远没活过 23 岁？我看着他，我一直以为他大概，你知道的，就像个真正的男人。我刚和罗恩·哈德森、伊丽莎白·泰勒一起看了他演的《巨人传》。只有《巨人传》。肖恩的又一条热辣点评。
Tracy, it's just Giant. Yeah. How was that? Was that part of the... Hey, you know what's a great movie? Gone with the Wind. You guys seen that? Nothing's really gone. Nothing leaves.
特雷西，这就是《巨人传》。对。感觉怎么样？那是……的一部分。嘿，你知道什么是一部好电影吗？《乱世佳人》。你们看过吗？没有什么真正的消逝。没有什么会离开。
I mean, there's a fire, but... It's got legs. Yeah, I know it was really long, but it was good. I didn't know it was based on... Dallas was based on it. The show Dallas was based on giant Oh, yeah. Anyway, let's continue. Yeah, James Dean. I think this is one of his last movies or his last movie Wait a second. Hang on a second. This is like
我的意思是，有一场大火，但……它很有生命力。对，我知道它真的很长，但很好。我不知道它是基于……《达拉斯》就是基于它改编的。《达拉斯》这部剧就是基于《巨人传》改编的。哦，对。不管怎样，我们继续。对，詹姆斯·迪恩。我觉得这是他的最后几部电影之一，或者就是他的最后一部电影。等等。等一下。这就像
Like a fucking and you're like, what am I doing? Why am I but is that a known fact or is that a weird? Reddit thing that that Dallas was based on no guys name is JR I mean his initials are JR and giant oil king and blah blah blah blah blah weird Reddit thing that Dallas was based on. No, the guy's name is JR. I mean his initials are JR. And giant is an oil king and blah blah blah blah blah. Yeah. You're sure?
像一个他妈的……然后你就会想，我在干什么？我为什么要……但这是一个众所周知的客观事实，还是一个诡异的红迪网说法，说《达拉斯》是基于它改编的？不，伙计们，那家伙叫 JR。我的意思是他的名字缩写是 JR，而《巨人传》里是个石油大亨，等等等等……诡异的红迪网说法，说《达拉斯》是基于它改编的。不，那家伙叫 JR。我的意思是他的名字缩写是 JR。而《巨人传》里是个石油大亨，等等等等。对。你确定？
100% positive. Oh, okay. And then what Not's Landing was based on. Love it if Scottie just slid in on a rolling stool. Well that was based on. Just for what it's worth, A Place in the Sun with Montgomery Clift is an amazing movie. Sorry, I just thought we were doing random.
100% 确定。哦，好吧。那《诺茨兰丁》又是基于什么改编的。真希望斯科蒂能坐着带轮子的凳子滑进来。好吧，那是以什么为基础的。顺便说一句，蒙哥马利·克利夫特主演的《郎心如铁》是一部极其出色的电影。抱歉，我还以为我们在随机聊呢。
Rashida, let's get to the guests. Will, do you have any questions for your guests? Yeah, would you back off? Come on. Your attitude is so shit. Go eat something for fuck's sake and then come back at me. Too much oatmeal is the problem. Sorry, Rashida.
拉什达，我们谈谈嘉宾吧。威尔，你对你的嘉宾有什么问题吗？对，你能克制点吗？拜托。你的态度太糟糕了。看在上帝的份上，吃点东西再来反驳我吧。问题是燕麦吃太多了。抱歉，拉什达。
Jason pulled up his shirt last night and I saw his abs, crazy abs. Really? Oh my God. It's a leaky three pack. Like summer abs? But not by choice, just from diet. No. Yeah, well I'm playing with God.
杰森昨晚掀起衬衫，我看到了他的腹肌，疯狂的腹肌。真的吗？哦，天哪。这是一个漏风的六块腹肌的三块。就像夏日腹肌？但不是自愿的，纯粹是因为节食。没有。对，好吧，我在跟上帝开玩笑。
There's no sugar, there's no sugar, dairy? There's no food. There's no dinner. There's no food. There's no dinner. There's no sugar, no dinner. That's the key. Intermittent fasting, that's what you do?
没有糖，没有糖，乳制品？没有食物。没有晚餐。没有食物。没有晚餐。没有糖，没有晚餐。这就是关键。间歇性禁食，这就是你的做法？
It's unintentional, but it's, yeah, I'm playing. Intermittent eating. Yeah, that's it Wow, are you hungry all the time? It's are you hungry and grumpy all the time? No, you get you get you get past it You just got you know that you got a race to get to sleep. You got to get to bed You got to get to sleep. He thinks it's discipline. Oh, it is definitely just it's mental illness, bro Yeah
这是无意的，但它，是的，我在开玩笑。间歇性进食。对，就是这样。哇，你一直都很饿吗？你是不是一直又饿又暴躁？不，你挺过去了，你挺过去了。你只需要知道你得赶快去睡觉。你得去睡觉。你得去睡觉。他以为这是自律。哦，这绝对只是心理疾病，老兄。对。
For different things So wait, so Rashida I want to touch you a little bit about so your experience illness, bro, at this point. People have different words for different things. You know? So wait, so Rashida, I want to touch you a little bit about, so your experience, everybody knows you from The Office and from Parks and Rec, and then, but everybody knew you as this actress, and you were kind of working in comedy and TV, and then you started, you and, I want to say that you,
为了不同的事情。所以等等，拉什达，我想稍微聊聊你的经历……疾病，老兄，到这个地步了。人们对不同的事情有不同的说法。你知道吗？所以等等，拉什达，我想稍微聊聊，关于你的经历，大家都知道你演过《办公室》和《公园与游憩》，然后，但大家都知道你是一个演员，你之前主要从事喜剧和电视工作，然后你开始，你和，我想说，
I don't know how long you knew Will McCormick for, but you guys teamed up, you started writing, and you just started writing all your own stuff. Like you kind of made this shift at a certain point. Was that like a conscious decision? You're like, I've always had all these ideas and I'm sick of doing other people's stuff, I just wanna do my own shit?
我不知道你认识威尔·麦考密克多久了，但你们合作了，你们开始写作，然后你们开始创作你们自己的所有作品。就像你在某个特定时刻完成了这种转型。这是一个有意识的决定吗？你是不是想，我一直都有这些点子，我厌倦了演别人的东西，我只想搞我自己的？
Yeah, I always wanted to be a writer, but I didn't feel like I was good enough or anointed to be that kind of person. I think probably because I went to school with a lot of people who ended up writing for television. Harvard. Did you really go to Harvard? And they were all in the lampoon and they were funny and the guys who were going to get the jobs and stuff. So I never felt like that.
对，我一直想成为一名编剧，但我觉得自己不够优秀，也没有被赋予成为那种人的资格。我想可能是因为我和很多后来为电视写剧本的人一起上过学。哈佛。你真的去过哈佛吗？他们都在讽刺杂志社，他们很搞笑，那些能拿到工作的人什么的。所以我从来没有那种感觉。
So I didn't feel worthy like pursuing that. And then a strike happened. Did you know Sure, did you know Mike Sure at Harvard? Yeah. Mike Sure's the one who created Parks and Rec? We met freshman year. We did a play together freshman year
所以我觉得自己不配去追求那个。然后罢工发生了。你知道……当然，你在哈佛认识迈克·舒尔吗？对。迈克·舒尔就是《公园与游憩》的创作者？我们在大一认识的。我们在大一一起演过一出戏。
called Love, Sex, and the IRS. Love, Sex, and the IRS. Wait, was it? It opened with us making out. Was he acting? Yeah. How was acting? Yeah. How was he? Yeah, funny.
叫《爱、性与国税局》。《爱、性与国税局》。等等，是吗？一开场就是我们在热吻。他在演戏吗？对。演得怎么样？对。他怎么样？对，挺搞笑的。
I'll bet he's great. Yeah, he was funny, he was great. Yeah, I bet he is great, yeah. Mike Schur, yeah, for Tracy, Mike Schur started SNL and he was head writer of Weekend Update and then he went to the office and then he went with Greg Daniels and they created Parks and Rec
我敢说他很棒。对，他很搞笑，他很棒。对，我敢说他确实很棒，对。迈克·舒尔，对，对于特雷西来说，迈克·舒尔创办了 SNL，他是《周末夜现场》的首席编剧，然后他去了《办公室》，然后他和格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起创作了《公园与游憩》，
and then he went on to do Brooklyn Nine-Nine and The Good Place and tons of other stuff. He's a brilliant writer and you guys have a long relationship. I feel like I kind of know Sher through SNL but also kind of through you because you guys were friends. Yeah, since we were 18. Yeah, that's amazing.
接着他去做了《神烦警探》和《善地》以及一大堆其他东西。他是一个才华横溢的编剧，你们有着长期的合作关系。我觉得我通过 SNL 了解舒尔，但也通过你了解他，因为你们是朋友。对，从我们 18 岁起。对，太惊人了。
We wrote a paper together in college, by the way. How stupid is that? We convinced our teacher that we should write a paper together. For the class, the Warren Court. What is that? About the Warren Commission? About the Supreme Court Justice Warren.
顺便说一句，我们在大学里一起写过一篇论文。有多蠢？我们说服老师我们应该一起写一篇论文。为了那门课，沃伦法院。那是什么？关于沃伦委员会？关于最高法院大法官沃伦。
Ah ha. Wow. I'd love to read your paper. It sounds hilarious. It sounds really funny. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Now wait, so, get me back to the writing part of it.
啊哈。哇。我很想读读你们的论文。听起来太滑稽了。听起来真的很好笑。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。等等，那么，把话题带回写作部分。
Did you, what gave you kind of the fuel to like say, well you know what, maybe I can, or maybe I should? Did it come from just getting more and more proud of your writing, or were you reading more and more things that were not great that were getting produced? And you were like, I can do at least that. I think it was that. I think you just read so much when you're auditioning,
是什麽给了你动力让你说，好吧，你知道吗，也许我可以，或者也许我应该？是因为你对自己的写作越来越自豪，还是你读了越来越多并不怎么样却被搬上银幕的作品？然后你想，至少我能做到那样。我想是这样的。我想你在试镜的时候读了太多剧本，
and even if you're not getting jobs, you just see the kind of landscape of what people are writing, and obviously there was good stuff, but I was kind of inspired by that moment in time that like the peak Judd Apatow where like all those dudes were just like, just writing themselves, you know?
即使你没有得到工作，你也能看到大家都在写什么类型的作品，显然有好作品，但我当时受到那个时代贾德·阿帕图巅峰时期的启发，那群家伙就是……就是自己写自己拍，你知道吗？
And I thought I could at least do that, right? Even if it's not as good or as funny, I could find some audience. And I also had this feeling that like, nobody would ever cast me as a certain kind of thing. And if I'm going to get that part, I probably have to write it for myself. You know what, it's so funny, when I was living in Chicago,
我觉得至少我能做到那一点，对吧？即使它没那么好，没那么搞笑，我也能找到一些观众。而且我当时有一种感觉，没有人会把我塑造成某种特定类型的人。如果我要得到那个角色，我可能得为自己写。你知道吗，太搞笑了，当我住在芝加哥的时候，
I would watch certain channels that no longer exist. And on those channels were shows that no longer exist, and they weren't really great. And I was really young, and I was like, I know I can be at least that bad. Like, if that's all that's required, there's gotta be some job for me somewhere. You know what I mean?
我会看一些现在已经不存在的频道。在那些频道上有现在已经不存在的节目，它们其实并不算出色。我当时很年轻，我在想，我至少能达到那种烂的程度。如果这就是全部要求的话，那某处一定有适合我的工作。你知道我的意思吗？
Because they're not fantastic. Anyway, that was my... I wasn't saying that about, no, I'm not saying that about, but you know what I mean? Like I saw the entire spectrum and I thought, there's somewhere I can land. And of course I had lofty dreams because I grew up on Jim Brooks and Nora Ephron
因为它们并不惊艳。不管怎样，那是我的……我不是在说那个，不，我不是在说那个，但你知道我的意思吗？就像我看到了整个光谱，然后我想，总有我能立足的地方。当然，我曾有过崇高的梦想，因为我是看着吉姆·布鲁克斯和诺拉·埃夫伦长大的，
and those were the kinds of movies I wanted to be in and I wanted to write. And I think having Bill holding each other's hands through the process, like we literally sat side-side and wrote our first script together and I feel like that. How did that relationship start? How'd you guys? We were set up. We were set up by his sister Mary McCormick. You must know Mary McCormick. I know and love, yes. Of course we love Mary.
那些是我想要参演、想要去写的电影。而且我觉得有比尔在这个过程中彼此手拉手，我们真的是并肩坐在一起写了我们的第一个剧本，我觉得……这段关系是怎么开始的？你们是怎么……我们是被撮合的。我们是被他的姐姐玛丽·麦考密克撮合的。你一定认识玛丽·麦考密克。我认识并爱她，是的。我们当然爱玛丽。
I did a movie in the 90s, indie movie with Mary and I was obsessed with her. She was like the coolest, funniest person I'd ever met. She was like, you should go out with my brother. You guys are soulmates. And she's not wrong, it didn't work out. We did date for three weeks, it didn't work out. But he kind of is my work soulmate, you know?
我在 90 年代拍过一部电影，是一部和玛丽合作的独立电影，我当时迷恋死她了。她就像我见过的最酷、最搞笑的人。她说，你应该和我弟弟约会。你们是灵魂伴侣。她没说错，虽然没成。我们确实约会了三个星期，没成。但他某种程度上是我的工作灵魂伴侣，你知道吗？
We still work together, so. So you guys still work together, you and Will? Yeah, we produce and we write together. That's awesome, I love Will. He's such a good dude and Mary is so amazing. So you guys start, so you guys kind of have this, you realize, you date but it's not working out, but you realize that there is something else there
我们现在还在一起工作，所以。所以你们现在还在一起工作，你和威尔？对，我们一起制片，一起写作。太棒了，我喜欢威尔。他是个很好的人，玛丽也太棒了。所以你们开始，你们有点……你们意识到，你们约会了但行不通，但你们意识到还有别的东西。
on another, maybe potentially even deeper level that you connect on. And what was the first thing that you guys were like, hey, we need to write this. Like, how did that happen? We started writing, oh, it's so weird. No, we started writing a show in New York. I mean, we were just drunk.
在另一个可能甚至更深层次的层面上，你们产生了共鸣。你们一起写的第一个东西是什么？比如，那是怎么发生的？我们开始写，哦，太诡异了。不，我们在纽约开始写一部剧。我的意思是，我们当时只是喝醉了。
It's not even worth mentioning. The only thing we completed was Celeste and Jesse Forever, was the first movie that we completed, wrote to, in its entirety and went out with. Did you get, were you tempted to write about your relationship and how it did? Well we kinda, kinda, yeah, it kind of was that a little bit of it, it was like an amalgam of
根本不值得一提。我们唯一完成的作品是《曾经的吉尔和杰西》，这是我们完成并拿出去的第一部完整电影，从头到尾写完并推向市场。你有过想要写你们俩的关系以及它是如何……的冲动吗？好吧，我们有点……有点，对，多少有点那种成分，它有点像是融合了
the first kind of love that we had our own separate loves plus our dynamic as like a kind of somewhere in the middle of romantic and best friend chip yeah You just made me think of sorry to bounce around One of my favorite movies is social network. Was there any, your participation in that and having gone to Harvard, was there any, was any of that happening while you were there at that time? No, bro, no, I'm old, no.
我们各自经历的第一段爱，再加上我们作为介于浪漫关系和死党之间的那种动态关系。是的。你刚才让我想起……抱歉话题跳跃了一下……我最喜欢的电影之一是《社交网络》。你参与其中并去过哈佛，当时在你上学期间发生过那些事吗？没有，老兄，没有，我老了，没有。
So it was after you left? Yeah. I think it was like 2004. We had The FaceBook, which was the freshman Facebook, which is what the name is based on. And so like you'd get to school and you'd have, everybody would pick their headshots, you know. Like a yearbook.
所以那是你离开之后？对。我想大概是 2004 年。我们当时有 The FaceBook，也就是新生脸书，名字就是这么来的。所以当你到学校时，你会拿到，每个人都会选自己的证件照，你知道的。就像年鉴一样。
Yeah, like a yearbook, but you submit your picture. Yeah, that's pretty cool. Was it digital or was it a hard copy? Hard copy, digital? We had ethernet my senior year. There was no internet. Right, yeah, we're about the same age. No, you're younger than we are. I'm younger than you, come on.
对，就像年鉴，但你要提交自己的照片。对，挺酷的。是电子版的还是纸质版的？纸质版，电子版？我大四的时候通了以太网。那时候没有互联网。对，是的，我们差不多大。不，你比我们年轻。我比你们年轻，拜托。
Jason, you're the oldest one here, by the way. I know. How old are you? 55. Look at his face. Wow, you're 55? That's amazing. Yeah, there's some gray in my beard.
杰森，顺便说一句，你是这里年纪最大的。我知道。你多大？55 岁。看他的脸。哇，你 55 岁了？太惊人了。对，我的胡子里有些白头发。
Somewhere under that beard, you do look great. You look great, you look great. Just a lot of beard, but I see it. There's a hell of a back in the company. I'm playing a loser, so you know. Oh, you are? Yeah. Oh, in the movie.
在那胡子底下，你看上去状态真好。你看上去真棒，状态真棒。只是胡子太多了，但我看到了。公司里真是一大后盾。我在演一个失败者，所以你知道的。哦，是吗？对。哦，在电影里。
Oh, in the movie. In real life. My wife and I like role playing, and so this month she's got me as a loser. This month. Hey, growing up around so much music, I'm sure, there's constantly music in your house, I'm sure, right? Yeah, yeah.
哦，在电影里。现实生活中。我和我妻子喜欢角色扮演，所以这个月她把我设定为一个失败者。这个月。嘿，在那么多的音乐环境中长大，我确信，你家里肯定一直都有音乐，对吧？对，对。
And were you ever inspired to do that? Like, was your whole family like, wait, don't you want to come over here and do what we're doing? We're playing instruments, we're singing songs, we're producing records. I love it so much, and I kind of like sing for fun. I've written for fun and I've sung,
你曾经受到启发去做音乐吗？比如，你的家里人有没有说，等等，你难道不想过来做我们正在做的事吗？我们在弹乐器，我们在唱歌，我们在制作唱片。我太喜欢了，我挺喜欢为了好玩而唱歌的。我为了好玩写过歌，也唱过歌，
like I've sung backup on some albums and things like that. Really? Yeah, I sang backup on the first two Maroon 5s. No way. I sing for them live, yeah. That's so cool. That's so good. Wait, can you read music, can you write music?
比如我在一些专辑里唱过和声之类的。真的吗？对，我在魔力红前两张专辑里唱过和声。不会吧。我现场为他们伴唱，对。太酷了。太棒了。等等，你会识谱吗，你会写歌吗？
I can write. My reading is limited, but my dad's a musical genius. That's like the last thing I wanna do is try my hand at that. But I love it. I have a deep ache for music, and I just don't ever feel like I'm good enough to do it. I'll never be good enough to do it. Again, I wanna remind people,
我会写。我识谱有限，但我爸是个音乐天才。我最不想尝试的就是那个。但我喜欢它。我对音乐有着深深的渴望，但我从来不觉得自己足够优秀去从事它。我永远不够优秀去干这个。再次重申，我想提醒大家，
your dad produced Thriller. Yeah. Yeah. Right? So that's so, Jimmy, I remember one time, Rashida, going over to your dad's house with you and being blown away, going downstairs and seeing, you know when you go into somebody's office, guys,
你爸爸制作了《颤栗》。对。对吧？所以，吉姆，我记得有一次，拉什达，我和你一起去你爸爸家，被震撼到了，走到楼下看到，你知道当你走进某人的办公室时，伙计们，
and you see like, they've got like a record, right? Like a platinum record or whatever, like some whatever. And you go into Quincy's house and well, it is A, it's a museum and B, the framed thing for Thriller has like 40 platinum records in the frame. Literally 40, you're like, what the fuck? It's like the granddaddy of them all. And what about that documentary you did was just so awesome.
你会看到……他们有一张唱片，对吧？就像白金唱片什么的，或者诸如此类的东西。然后你走进昆西的家，A，那是一个博物馆，B，《颤栗》装裱起来的东西里面有大约 40 张白金唱片。字面意思上的 40 张，你会想，他妈的这是什么？这简直是所有唱片的老祖宗。你拍的那部纪录片真是太棒了。
Yes, that was so good. Yeah, so I was gonna talk about it. So let's get to the documentary about your dad. Yeah. What a great thing to do for your, I mean, for your parents, it's just like, I don't know. That was a lot of time. Well, I was gonna say, so, I mean, obviously we,
对，太棒了。对，我正要谈这个。那我们就来聊聊关于你父亲的纪录片吧。对。为你父母做这样一件事，我的意思是，真的，我不知道。那花了很多时间。好吧，我的意思是，显然我们，
you know, yeah, like Jason said, it's a great thing to do and to be able to do with your dad, but also like, what was, do you remember the moment where you're like, how that, the sort of the genesis of that? What was the moment? I'm not gonna take any credit. My dad is so well-documented.
你知道的，就像杰森说的，这是一件很棒的事，能和你的父亲一起完成，但还有，什么是……你还记得那个契机吗，你是怎么产生这个想法的？那个时刻是什么？我可不敢居功。我爸爸有太多关于他的记录了。
Like, he had it, there was a doc series on BBC, there was a documentary about him in the 80s, and I was with Jane Rosenthal, you know Jane. Yeah, the great Jane Rosenthal. Who's a legend, and she worked for my dad years ago, like 30 years ago. Oh wow. And she said to me, you have to make,
比如，BBC 做过关于他的纪录片系列，80 年代也有过关于他的纪录片，当时我和简·罗森塔尔在一起，你认识简。对，伟大的简·罗森塔尔。她是个传奇，她多年前为我父亲工作过，大约 30 年前。哦，哇。她对我说，你必须拍，
you have to make a documentary about your dad. And I was like, oh fuck, I do, I do, don't I? I didn't want to, but she was right. Because the truth is, he's so well documented, he's so accomplished that it's almost impossible to spend any time storytelling about who he is as a person to cover so much ground with just what he's like like Contributed to the world and culture I wanted to do something that felt like it captured his personality because nothing ever has and
你必须拍一部关于你父亲的纪录片。当时我就想，哦，操，我是得拍，我是得拍，对吧？我其实不想拍，但她是正确的。因为事实是，关于他的记录太详尽了，他取得的成就太伟大了，以至于几乎不可能花时间去讲述他作为一个人的故事，去涵盖他为世界和文化做出的那么多贡献。我想拍一部能捕捉到他性格本质的纪录片，因为从来没有人做到过，
So that was kind of the goal. And then Al Hicks, who I love. By the way, if you've never seen, he made a documentary called Keep On Keepin' On, which is about Clark Terry, who's my dad's mentor, horn player, and his last mentee, who's this incredible jazz pianist, he's blind, Justin Coughlin, it's like about their relationship.
所以这差不多就是我的目标。然后艾尔·希克斯（Al Hicks），我很喜欢他。顺便说一句，如果你没看过，他拍过一部名为《坚持到底》（Keep On Keepin' On）的纪录片，讲的是克拉克·特里（Clark Terry），我父亲的导师、小号手，以及他的最后一个门徒、那位不可思议的爵士钢琴家贾斯汀·考夫林（Justin Kauflin）是盲人，讲的是他们的关系。
It's like, if you're ready to cry, that's what you turn on. Like it's like waterworks. It's so good. Keep on keepin' on? Keep on keepin' on. So Hicks, he directed that. We met on my first day of filming in Montreux
就像，如果你准备好哭了，就去看这部。简直是催泪弹。太棒了。《坚持到底》？《坚持到底》。所以希克斯，他执导了那部片子。我们在蒙特勒的第一天拍摄时认识的，
in Switzerland at the Jazz Festival. I had a 5D camera. I was trying to figure out what to do, how to do it. And we met that day and then I asked him to co-direct with me. Wow. Yeah, and I mean just the access, so yeah, all that archival footage
在瑞士的爵士音乐节上。我当时拿着一台 5D 相机。我正试图弄清楚该做什么、怎么做。我们那天见面了，然后我邀请他和我联合执导。哇。对，我的意思是，仅仅是拍摄权限，所以，关于你父亲的所有那些资料画面，
that people have already seen about your dad, no one's seen you just walking around with a camera in the house and talking to your dad. Right, that was really cool. That was just like this access, it just felt so privileged watching it. Yeah, it felt intimate and too intimate, in fact, because there's a whole scene where,
人们以前都看过了，但没有人看过你拿着相机在家里走来走去并和你爸爸聊天。对，那真的很酷。那样的近距离接触，看的时候感觉享有特权。对，感觉很亲密，甚至说过于亲密了，事实上，因为里面有一整段，
I mean, he almost died while we were filming. Right, oh, yeah. We stopped filming, and luckily my brother was filming a bunch of stuff in the hospital, like, show my dad, because he went into diabetic coma. And, you know, luckily the conclusion of the story was such that we could put it in and felt like the real triumph through that because my dad is a beast
我的意思是，我们拍摄时他差点死掉。对，哦，对。我们暂停了拍摄，幸运的是我弟弟在医院里拍了很多东西，比如，给我爸看，因为他陷入了糖尿病昏迷。而且，你知道，幸运的是，故事的结局还算不错，我们可以把它剪进去，感觉那是通过这一切取得的真正胜利，因为我爸爸是个硬汉，
and he has cheated death many times. 91, still crushing it. So. That's amazing, yeah. You know what was fascinating to me watching that was seeing you in the document, because you told me like, you have to check out this documentary.
他多次死里逃生。91 岁了，依然生龙活虎。所以。太惊人了，对。看那个的时候让我觉得着迷的是看到你在纪录片里，因为你对我说过，你一定要去看看这部纪录片。
I ran home and watched it. And there's my friend, Rashida Jones. And I'm watching Rashida Jones interview her dad, who's Quincy Jones. And I had this weird thing where like, wait, they're related? Which is a compliment because- That's really nice, I take that.
我跑回家看了。里面有我的朋友拉什达·琼斯。我看着拉什达·琼斯采访她的父亲昆西·琼斯。我当时有一种奇怪的感觉，就像，等等，他们有亲戚关系？这是一个赞美，因为——这真的很好，我接受了。
You've become, you've made such a world for yourself, separate from his huge world, and you've both become hugely successful, that it was wild just to see, wow, that you both became. Well, it's true, Rashidi, and that was also something I wanted to get to, which is like, it's not easy, I can imagine, I can only imagine, how to,
你已经建立了自己的广阔天地，独立于他庞大的世界之外，你们都取得了巨大的成功，所以看到你们两个都成长为……这真的很疯狂。没错，拉什达，这也是我想谈的一点，那就是，这并不容易，我可以想象，我只能想象，如何去……
and it's not by anybody's fault or design that you have a dad who is larger than life, who is, as you said, a musical genius. Everybody knows he's created incredible things. He's done amazing things. And to grow up with that, I can only imagine there's a lot there. And then you go to Harvard and get...
而且这并不是因为任何人的过错或刻意安排，你有一个高大上的父亲，正如你所说，他是一个音乐天才。每个人都知道他创造了不可思议的事物。他做过惊人的事情。伴随着这些长大，我只能想象那里面有很多东西。然后你去了哈佛并获得了……
To create your own thing and to have your own incredible success. That's a real there. I'll just say that. And then you go to Harvard and get... And then to create your own thing and to have your own incredible success, that's a real testament to your talent. I hope you recognize that. Yeah, to have the courage to even try. And then you nailed it. And now people are like, wait, she has a famous dad?
To create your own thing and to have your own incredible success. That's a real there. I'll just say that. And then you go to Harvard and get... And then to create your own thing and to have your own incredible success, that's a real testament to your talent. I hope you recognize that. Yeah, to have the courage to even try. And then you nailed it. And now people are like, wait, she has a famous dad?|||创造属于自己的东西并取得令人难以置信的成功。这真的很了不起。我只想说这些。然后你去了哈佛，获得了……接着能打造属于你自己的事业并取得不可思议的成功，这绝对是对你才华的证明。我希望你能认识到这一点。是的，甚至需要勇气去尝试。然后你成功了。现在人们都在想，等等，她有个有名的爸爸？
You know, it's like, you've already got your own thing. It's Janet and Michael. It's Janet Jackson and Michael Jackson. I never think of them in the same family. Oh, his mother, Janet? No. No, but It's Janet Jackson and Michael Jackson. I never think of them in the same family. Oh, his mother, Janet? No, but like Janet Jackson and Michael Jackson are in the same family, but when I see them,
You know, it's like, you've already got your own thing. It's Janet and Michael. It's Janet Jackson and Michael Jackson. I never think of them in the same family. Oh, his mother, Janet? No. No, but It's Janet Jackson and Michael Jackson. I never think of them in the same family. Oh, his mother, Janet? No, but like Janet Jackson and Michael Jackson are in the same family, but when I see them,|||你知道的，就像是，你已经有你自己的成就了。就像珍妮和迈克尔。就像珍妮·杰克逊和迈克尔·杰克逊。我从来没把他们联想成是一家人。哦，他的母亲是珍妮？不。不，但是 珍妮·杰克逊和迈克尔·杰克逊。我从来没把他们当成一家人。哦，他妈妈叫珍妮？不，但就像珍妮·杰克逊和迈克尔·杰克逊其实是一家人，但每当我看到他们时，
I'm like, I don't think of the other one. Right. It's not a great analogy, also. It's too close. It's too close with Michael and stuff. All right, sorry, sorry. No, I mean, we would cut it, but we want to shame you, so we're gonna leave it in.
I'm like, I don't think of the other one. Right. It's not a great analogy, also. It's too close. It's too close with Michael and stuff. All right, sorry, sorry. No, I mean, we would cut it, but we want to shame you, so we're gonna leave it in.|||我会觉得，我不会想到另一个。对的。而且这个比喻不太恰当。太接近了。和迈克尔什么的太接近了。好吧，抱歉，抱歉。不，我的意思是，我们本来可以剪掉的，但我们想让你出丑，所以我们决定保留这段。
We might open the episode with it. Yeah, yeah. Have you seen The Godfather? Just kidding. No, I heard you guys talking about that, and we actually did, we watched it recently too, we watched all three. And great films, great films.
We might open the episode with it. Yeah, yeah. Have you seen The Godfather? Just kidding. No, I heard you guys talking about that, and we actually did, we watched it recently too, we watched all three. And great films, great films.|||我们可能会用这个来作为节目的开场。对，对。你看过《教父》吗？开玩笑的。不，我听到你们在讨论这个，其实我们最近也看了，我们把三部都看了。非常棒的电影，伟大的电影。
I don't know if anybody knows, but really great films. And three, great film. I don't know if, I think we watched the edited version, but I watched it because I hadn't seen it since I know Sofia so well, and just seeing like baby Sofia in that movie. First on screen, wasn't it? You know what's crazy about Three, you guys?
I don't know if anybody knows, but really great films. And three, great film. I don't know if, I think we watched the edited version, but I watched it because I hadn't seen it since I know Sofia so well, and just seeing like baby Sofia in that movie. First on screen, wasn't it? You know what's crazy about Three, you guys?|||我不知道有没有人知道，但真的是很棒的电影。第三部也是，非常棒的电影。我不知道，我想我们看的是剪辑版，但我看是因为我认识索菲亚很久了，而且一直没看过，看到电影里那个还是婴儿的索菲亚。那是她第一次出镜吧？你们知道第三部最疯狂的地方是什么吗？
It's about first cousins in love. I know. It's wild. I just started watching it. And that's not the central conflict of the movie. It's just a story. Well, so you mentioned Sophia Kobla. So you made a film with Sophia,
It's about first cousins in love. I know. It's wild. I just started watching it. And that's not the central conflict of the movie. It's just a story. Well, so you mentioned Sophia Kobla. So you made a film with Sophia,|||讲的是表兄妹谈恋爱。我知道。太离谱了。我刚开始看的时候。但这并不是电影的核心冲突。它只是一个故事。好吧，既然你提到了索菲亚·科波拉。所以你和索菲亚合作拍了一部电影，
I wanna say five, four or five years ago, right? On the Rocks? Yeah, 2020. Well, it came out during lockdown. So yeah, 2020. Sorry, I don't know what you're talking about. I blanked that part out of my head. I mean, completely.
I wanna say five, four or five years ago, right? On the Rocks? Yeah, 2020. Well, it came out during lockdown. So yeah, 2020. Sorry, I don't know what you're talking about. I blanked that part out of my head. I mean, completely.|||我想说是五年前，四、五年年前吧？《触礁》？对，2020年。嗯，是在封城期间上映的。所以是的，2020年。抱歉，我不知道你在说什么。我把那段记忆从脑子里删除了。我是说，彻底删除了。
Yes, we all have. I don't know what you mean. So you made this film on the box in 2020 with Sofia Coppola and Bill Murray. Yeah. And you got a lot of great reviews for that performance. I mean, everybody loved it. And did you know Sophia before
Yes, we all have. I don't know what you mean. So you made this film on the box in 2020 with Sofia Coppola and Bill Murray. Yeah. And you got a lot of great reviews for that performance. I mean, everybody loved it. And did you know Sophia before|||是的，我们都一样。我不知道你在说什么。所以你在2020年和索菲亚·科波拉以及比尔·默瑞合作了这部电影《触礁》。对的。你的表演获得了许多极好的评价。我是说，每个人都很喜欢。那你之前就认识索菲亚吗？
or was that where you guys kind of got to know each other? We had met, I was like an out of work actor in an acting class in New York. And she came to the class to workshop Lost in Translation. What? And so I played the like main part for a month with her. No, wait, wait, walk me through that idea. What is that?
or was that where you guys kind of got to know each other? We had met, I was like an out of work actor in an acting class in New York. And she came to the class to workshop Lost in Translation. What? And so I played the like main part for a month with her. No, wait, wait, walk me through that idea. What is that?|||还是你们是在那时候才开始互相了解的？我们见过面，当时我在纽约的一个表演班里，是个失业演员。她来班里为《迷失东京》做工作坊。什么？然后我和她一起排练了一个月的主角。不，等等，等等，跟我讲讲这个过程。那是怎么回事？
So my acting coach, Greta, works a lot with Frances and Sophia. And they do dream work around character dream work. And so she kind of came to explore and enrich like the characters in the film. And so I was like assigned to the lead part to the Scarlett Johansson part. And then, you know, I had to do like dream assignments
So my acting coach, Greta, works a lot with Frances and Sophia. And they do dream work around character dream work. And so she kind of came to explore and enrich like the characters in the film. And so I was like assigned to the lead part to the Scarlett Johansson part. And then, you know, I had to do like dream assignments|||所以我的表演教练格雷塔经常与弗朗西丝和索菲亚合作。他们围绕角色的“梦境工作”展开创作。所以她来是为了探索和丰富电影中的角色。然后我被指派出演主角，也就是斯嘉丽·约翰逊的角色。然后，你知道的，我必须做一些梦境作业，
and come in and like, you know, embarrass myself by acting out my dreams. But it was really very cool. Like I got to play that part and work with Sophia for like a month. I was like 27 or something? 26, 27? Wow. Wow, that's pretty cool.
and come in and like, you know, embarrass myself by acting out my dreams. But it was really very cool. Like I got to play that part and work with Sophia for like a month. I was like 27 or something? 26, 27? Wow. Wow, that's pretty cool.|||然后来……你知道的，通过把我的梦境表演出来而出洋相。但真的很酷。就像我有机会演那个角色，并和索菲亚合作了一个月左右。我当时大概27岁左右？26、27岁？哇。哇，那太酷了。
That is cool. Also shot in Japan. I didn't get the part, but that's fine. Didn't even audition. So, but you didn't get the part, but you got to have a sort of a really intense working relationship with Sofia. And you guys stayed together. We were like, we got gotta do something at some point. That's the kind of vibe, or?
That is cool. Also shot in Japan. I didn't get the part, but that's fine. Didn't even audition. So, but you didn't get the part, but you got to have a sort of a really intense working relationship with Sofia. And you guys stayed together. We were like, we got gotta do something at some point. That's the kind of vibe, or?|||真的很酷。还在日本拍摄。我没得到这个角色，但没关系。甚至都没去试镜。所以，虽然你没得到那个角色，但你和索菲亚建立了一种非常紧密的合作关系。而且你们一直保持联系。我们当时觉得，我们总有一天得一起做点什么。就是那种氛围，是吗？
I mean, obviously I would've done anything for her. But we stayed friends over the years, and then I shot, we did, she directed a Calvin Klein underwear commercial that I was in. Wow. And then she did this Bill Murray Christmas special for Netflix. Right, yeah.
I mean, obviously I would've done anything for her. But we stayed friends over the years, and then I shot, we did, she directed a Calvin Klein underwear commercial that I was in. Wow. And then she did this Bill Murray Christmas special for Netflix. Right, yeah.|||我的意思是，显然为了她我什么都愿意做。但这些年来我们一直是朋友，后来我拍了，我们合作了，她执导了一支Calvin Klein的内衣广告，我出演了。哇。然后她为Netflix制作了这个比尔·默瑞的圣诞特别节目。对，是的。
And we had a little scene in that, and she was like, there's something happening here. This is a good dynamic, and I think she got the idea sort of from that scene we had together. Nice. And that. But what was that like working with Bill Murray? I know a lot of people.
And we had a little scene in that, and she was like, there's something happening here. This is a good dynamic, and I think she got the idea sort of from that scene we had together. Nice. And that. But what was that like working with Bill Murray? I know a lot of people.|||我们在里面有一个小片段，然后她说，这里面有点化学反应。这种互动感觉不错，我想她大概就是从我们一起拍的那个场景中获得了灵感。太好了。就是这样。但是和比尔·默瑞合作是什么感觉？我知道很多人……
I know. I mean, you don't really talk to many people that work with him. I know. there is as lucid as he is Yeah By the way thought about that that's true. We have we when we were doing that workshop Sophia was trying to cast him and she had a Dedicated assistant who sat outside our rehearsals with a phone waiting for him to call back all day God, it's amazing.
I know. I mean, you don't really talk to many people that work with him. I know. there is as lucid as he is Yeah By the way thought about that that's true. We have we when we were doing that workshop Sophia was trying to cast him and she had a Dedicated assistant who sat outside our rehearsals with a phone waiting for him to call back all day God, it's amazing.|||我知道。我的意思是，你真的不会经常和跟他合作过的人聊天。我懂。他是那么清醒，是的。顺便想想看，确实如此。我们当时在做那个工作坊时，索菲亚正试图选定他，她有一个专职助理坐在我们排练室外面，拿着电话整天等他回电话。天哪，太惊人了。
Yeah. Right? By the way, she already had a relationship with him, had a successful film with him and stuff, but she still had to have that. No, no, no, that was for Lost in Translation. That was before. Oh, that was for Lost in Translation.
Yeah. Right? By the way, she already had a relationship with him, had a successful film with him and stuff, but she still had to have that. No, no, no, that was for Lost in Translation. That was before. Oh, that was for Lost in Translation.|||对。对吧？顺便说一句，她当时已经跟他有过合作关系，跟他合作过成功的电影之类的，但她还是得经历这些。不，不，不，那是为了《迷失东京》。那是之前的事。哦，那是为了《迷失东京》。
Got it. Yes, that was originally when I met her and we were working on that. She had not cast him, she was still courting him. And you know, he's like a Loch Ness monster. Because the story goes like you can only reach him via fax or something like that? I know, yeah, I guess.
Got it. Yes, that was originally when I met her and we were working on that. She had not cast him, she was still courting him. And you know, he's like a Loch Ness monster. Because the story goes like you can only reach him via fax or something like that? I know, yeah, I guess.|||明白了。是的，那正是我最初遇到她并参与工作的时候。她还没定下他，她还在争取他。而且你知道，他就像尼斯湖水怪一样神秘。因为传闻说你只能通过传真或者类似的方式联系到他？我知道，是的，我猜是的。
I've never had that. He's got a phone number that you can call and leave a message. He had like a toll free number or something for a while. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I remember that, yeah. But he really is like, he did a guest spot. I had a show called Angie Trebekah. Yes.
I've never had that. He's got a phone number that you can call and leave a message. He had like a toll free number or something for a while. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I remember that, yeah. But he really is like, he did a guest spot. I had a show called Angie Trebekah. Yes.|||我从来没有那样过。他有一个电话号码，你可以打过去留言。他有一段时间好像还有一个免费电话号码什么的。对，对，对，我记得那个，对。但他真的是……他客串过。我当时有一个节目叫《安吉·特雷贝卡》。是的。
And he did a guest spot and he called me and I booked his ticket. He was like, oh yeah, I wanna leave at nine. Oh no way. On Wednesday, I was like, okay. That's funny. Are you serious? Shiet Blue, yeah, yeah. That's funny. No way.
And he did a guest spot and he called me and I booked his ticket. He was like, oh yeah, I wanna leave at nine. Oh no way. On Wednesday, I was like, okay. That's funny. Are you serious? Shiet Blue, yeah, yeah. That's funny. No way.|||他来客串了，他给我打了电话，然后我帮他订了机票。他说：“哦，对了，我想在九点离开。”哦，不会吧。周三，我说：“好吧。”太逗了。你认真的吗？Shuai Blue，对，对。真搞笑。不会吧。
And is he just about as chill and sort of don't sweat the small stuff as he seems? He's pretty great. I mean, he is extremely charismatic. You know, he's like, and he's also, what I didn't really know, I'd worked with him a couple times before, but doing a whole movie with him,
And is he just about as chill and sort of don't sweat the small stuff as he seems? He's pretty great. I mean, he is extremely charismatic. You know, he's like, and he's also, what I didn't really know, I'd worked with him a couple times before, but doing a whole movie with him,|||而且他真的像表面看起来那么随和、不拘小节吗？他挺棒的。我的意思是，他极具个人魅力。你知道，他就像是……而且还有一点我之前并不知道，虽然我以前跟他合作过几次，但和他一起拍整部电影……
like he's so, he's so good, he's so good. I'm not saying anything you don't know, but he's such a good actor and he's so, he's so present and he still works hard as an actor. He's not checked out. He could be checked out because his talent is undeniable. But he works hard. He had a lot of big meaty monologues in that movie
like he's so, he's so good, he's so good. I'm not saying anything you don't know, but he's such a good actor and he's so, he's so present and he still works hard as an actor. He's not checked out. He could be checked out because his talent is undeniable. But he works hard. He had a lot of big meaty monologues in that movie|||就觉得他太棒了，太棒了。我说的并不是你们不知道的事，但他真的是个非常出色的演员，他完全融入其中，并且作为一名演员他依然非常努力。他没有心不在焉。他完全可以敷衍了事，因为他的才华是不容置疑的。但他真的很努力。他在那部电影中有很多大段、极具分量的独白，
where he would talk about evolutionary biology and the nature of men and women. And it was a lot. He had to run down some serious theories and he was fully committed. You know, inspiring. I would love to have him on this show and ask him questions for an hour.
where he would talk about evolutionary biology and the nature of men and women. And it was a lot. He had to run down some serious theories and he was fully committed. You know, inspiring. I would love to have him on this show and ask him questions for an hour.|||他在其中大谈进化生物学以及男人的本性和女人的本性。内容非常多。他必须把一些严肃的理论倒背如流，而且他全身心地投入进去了。你知道的，这很鼓舞人心。我很乐意请他来这个节目，然后问他一个小时的问题。
Did you, wait, first of all. Well, why don't you wait out in the hall with the phone. Yeah, by the way. Exactly. Not good enough? I get it, Murray. Wow. Yeah, Jesus. Already thinking about the next guest.
Did you, wait, first of all. Well, why don't you wait out in the hall with the phone. Yeah, by the way. Exactly. Not good enough? I get it, Murray. Wow. Yeah, Jesus. Already thinking about the next guest.|||你……等等，首先。好吧，你怎么不去走廊里拿着电话等呢。是的，顺便说一句。没错。还不够好？我懂了，默瑞。哇。天哪。已经在想下一个嘉宾了。
Already thinking about old Bill Murray. Yeah, Jesus. Already thinking about the next guest. Already thinking about old Bill Murray. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. All right, so let's switch gears. All of a sudden, now you find yourself in with the gang over at Pixar, right? The crew. The crew,? The crew. The crew, the Pixar crew.
Already thinking about old Bill Murray. Yeah, Jesus. Already thinking about the next guest. Already thinking about old Bill Murray. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. All right, so let's switch gears. All of a sudden, now you find yourself in with the gang over at Pixar, right? The crew. The crew,? The crew. The crew, the Pixar crew.|||已经在想老比尔·默瑞了。是的，天哪。已经在想下一个嘉宾了。已经在想老比尔·默瑞了。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。好的，那我们换个话题。突然之间，你发现自己加入了皮克斯的团队，对吧？那个团队。团队？那个团队。这个团队，皮克斯的团队。
The Pixar crew, they approach you and they go, Rashida, we want you to come in here and start mixing it up on the Toy Story bonanza. How'd that go down? I mean, I love these Toy Story movies. I love Pixar movies so much. Yeah, I do too. Yeah, me too.
The Pixar crew, they approach you and they go, Rashida, we want you to come in here and start mixing it up on the Toy Story bonanza. How'd that go down? I mean, I love these Toy Story movies. I love Pixar movies so much. Yeah, I do too. Yeah, me too.|||皮克斯的团队，他们找到你并对你说：“拉什达，我们希望你加入进来，开始在《玩具总动员》的项目里大显身手。”事情是怎么发生的？我的意思是，我太喜欢这些《玩具总动员》电影了。我太喜欢皮克斯的电影了。是的，我也是。是的，我也是。
And it was, yeah, I was on Parks and, you know, they have really kind of cool development where every, you know, their development people, their casting people, they watch indie films. Like, that's how they get their ideas, you know. Like, I had had some friends who had written indie movies who had written there. And we went and screened Seles and Jesse Forever.
And it was, yeah, I was on Parks and, you know, they have really kind of cool development where every, you know, their development people, their casting people, they watch indie films. Like, that's how they get their ideas, you know. Like, I had had some friends who had written indie movies who had written there. And we went and screened Seles and Jesse Forever.|||那是……是的，我当时在拍《公园与游憩》，你知道的，他们有一种非常酷的开发模式，每个……你知道，他们的开发人员、选角人员，都会看独立电影。瞧，这就是他们获取灵感的方式。比如，我有些朋友写过独立电影，也曾在那里写过剧本。然后我们去放映了《塞尔斯和杰西永远》。
And then we got a call to meet on a project, all very, very under wraps, you know? Like they have to keep everything really. And we went and met and we got the job. And so I went to, sure. And I was like, listen, I love you. I love the show. I wanna be here, but I got a job.
And then we got a call to meet on a project, all very, very under wraps, you know? Like they have to keep everything really. And we went and met and we got the job. And so I went to, sure. And I was like, listen, I love you. I love the show. I wanna be here, but I got a job.|||然后我们接到电话去谈一个项目，一切都非常非常保密，你知道吗？就像他们必须严格保密所有事情一样。然后我们去了会面，我们就得到了这份工作。所以我就去……当然。我对他说：“听着，我爱你。我爱这个节目。我想留在这，但我得到了一份工作。”
It's at Pixar. I have to move to the Bay Area, and like, but I need your blessing, you know? And he was like, he's the greatest, he's the best boss ever, because he let everybody do everything they wanted to do while we were doing that show. Chris Pratt, they like filmed in London
It's at Pixar. I have to move to the Bay Area, and like, but I need your blessing, you know? And he was like, he's the greatest, he's the best boss ever, because he let everybody do everything they wanted to do while we were doing that show. Chris Pratt, they like filmed in London|||在皮克斯。我得搬到湾区去，而且……但我需要你的祝福，你知道吗？他当时说……他是最棒的，他是史上最好的老板，因为在我们拍那个节目期间，他让每个人都能做自己想做的事。克里斯·帕特，他们去伦敦拍戏，
so Pratt could do the first Marvel movie he did. He just wanted everybody to be like the best version of themselves, so he was like, yeah, of course, you have to go. How long did you live in the Bay Area to do that? I lived there two years. Wow.
so Pratt could do the first Marvel movie he did. He just wanted everybody to be like the best version of themselves, so he was like, yeah, of course, you have to go. How long did you live in the Bay Area to do that? I lived there two years. Wow.|||这样帕特就能去拍他第一部漫威电影了。他只是希望每个人都能成为最好的自己，所以他说：“行，当然，你必须去。”为了做这个，你在湾区住了多久？我在那里住了两年。哇。
Yeah. And you had to live there while you were writing it because the process is so sort of collaborative and back and forth? It's collaborative, it's iterative. You're rewriting a script every three weeks. It is not a WGA job. I'll just say that.
Yeah. And you had to live there while you were writing it because the process is so sort of collaborative and back and forth? It's collaborative, it's iterative. You're rewriting a script every three weeks. It is not a WGA job. I'll just say that.|||是的。你必须一边住在那里一边写作，因为这个过程非常具有合作性而且反反复复？它是合作性的，是迭代的。你每三周就要重写一次剧本。这不是一份美国编剧工会（WGA）的工作。我只能这么说。
And you're working with the story artists and they're sort of writing within the way that they draw, changes the story and then you have to change the script to fit the sequences they've. Yeah, one of the greatest documentaries I've ever seen is The Pixar Story. Yeah, they sit down and show that to you on your first they've... Yeah, one of the greatest documentaries I've ever seen is The Pixar Story. Yeah, they sit down and show that to you
And you're working with the story artists and they're sort of writing within the way that they draw, changes the story and then you have to change the script to fit the sequences they've. Yeah, one of the greatest documentaries I've ever seen is The Pixar Story. Yeah, they sit down and show that to you on your first they've... Yeah, one of the greatest documentaries I've ever seen is The Pixar Story. Yeah, they sit down and show that to you|||你在和故事板艺术家合作，他们的绘画方式在某种程度上改变了故事，然后你必须修改剧本以契合他们做出的分镜。是的，我看过最棒的纪录片之一就是《皮克斯的故事》。是的，他们会在你第一天去的时候坐下来放给你看……是的，我看过最棒的纪录片之一就是《皮克斯的故事》。是的，他们会坐下来放给你看
on your first day there. Yeah, they should, it's so fascinating. Yeah, I see that. And I did Monsters University, that little movie. And so I went up there too, and the whole facility is the coolest, like everybody's just playing ping pong and walking around, like, it's like college.
on your first day there. Yeah, they should, it's so fascinating. Yeah, I see that. And I did Monsters University, that little movie. And so I went up there too, and the whole facility is the coolest, like everybody's just playing ping pong and walking around, like, it's like college.|||在你去的第一天。是的，他们应该这么做，太迷人了。是的，我懂。我参与了《怪兽大学》那个小电影。所以我也去过那里，整个设施太酷了，每个人都在打乒乓球、到处闲逛，就像在大学里一样。
There's a vibe there, it's like a live there. It's like college. Yeah They're so good at ping-pong up there. They're so good at that's the one thing I love about picture is how good Yeah, I did one movie I did this ratatouille. It's not a big deal. Yeah With Brad Bird who cares movie that's a very played that great you've created that that great big huge dude right there No, he's the German sous chef. So good Fun movie with Brad Bird is such a gene. That guy's a genius. Yeah It feels like they send me a nice coffee table book every Christmas. Oh Yeah Just about just different subjects each each year just stuff, you know from everybody from your friends at Pixar belt boats. I'm very nice
There's a vibe there, it's like a live there. It's like college. Yeah They're so good at ping-pong up there. They're so good at that's the one thing I love about picture is how good Yeah, I did one movie I did this ratatouille. It's not a big deal. Yeah With Brad Bird who cares movie that's a very played that great you've created that that great big huge dude right there No, he's the German sous chef. So good Fun movie with Brad Bird is such a gene. That guy's a genius. Yeah It feels like they send me a nice coffee table book every Christmas. Oh Yeah Just about just different subjects each each year just stuff, you know from everybody from your friends at Pixar belt boats. I'm very nice|||那里有一种氛围，就像生活在那里一样。就像大学一样。是的，他们那里的乒乓球打得太好了。他们太擅长了，关于皮克斯我最喜欢的一点就是他们有多厉害。是的，我做过一部电影，我做了这部《料理鼠鼠》。没什么大不了的。是的，跟布拉德·伯德合作，谁在乎什么电影，那是一部非常……你塑造了那个身材高大魁梧的家伙对吧？不，他是那个德国副主厨。太棒了。和布拉德·伯德合作的有趣的电影，真是个天才。那家伙是个天才。是的，感觉他们每年圣诞节都会送我一本精美的咖啡桌读物。哦，是的。每年都是不同的主题，就是一些东西，你知道的，来自皮克斯朋友们的礼物。人太好了。
I really appreciate it Wait a lot of coffee tables. I drink a lot of coffee. Okay guys You and Jason both grew up in the valley. Did you ever run into each other? Have you known each other or no? You always ask each other. You don't remember do you? Don't know I, we've crossed paths. Uh oh. No, no, no, no, no, there's no raw stories. There's no raw stories.
I really appreciate it Wait a lot of coffee tables. I drink a lot of coffee. Okay guys You and Jason both grew up in the valley. Did you ever run into each other? Have you known each other or no? You always ask each other. You don't remember do you? Don't know I, we've crossed paths. Uh oh. No, no, no, no, no, there's no raw stories. There's no raw stories.|||我真的很感激。等等，得有很多咖啡桌才行。我喝很多咖啡。好吧，伙计们。你和杰森都是在圣费尔南多谷长大的。你们以前遇到过彼此吗？你们认识吗？你们总是问对方。你们不记得了吧？不知道，我……我们擦肩而过过。噢噢。不，不，不，不，不，没有什么惊心动魄的故事。没有什么疯狂的故事。
I just remember seeing you around and like, you were cute, all my friends liked you. I just feel like there's so much crossover. 80s, Valley? Yeah, but like where, was this before we were driving? Were we at kids parties? No, because you were driving when I was like 12. Yeah. Or 11.
I just remember seeing you around and like, you were cute, all my friends liked you. I just feel like there's so much crossover. 80s, Valley? Yeah, but like where, was this before we were driving? Were we at kids parties? No, because you were driving when I was like 12. Yeah. Or 11.|||我只记得经常看到你在附近晃悠，而且……你很可爱，我所有的朋友都喜欢你。我只是觉得我们的交集太多了。80年代的山谷？是的，但具体在哪里，这是在我们学会开车之前吗？我们在参加儿童派对吗？不对，因为我12岁左右的时候你已经在开车了。是的。或者11岁。
Yeah, right. But I feel like there was like, I'm trying to think of the 80s parties, 80s clubs. Well, sure, like Roxbury. Flippers, peanuts, Roxbury. Sounds like you didn't see each other. Well, I wasn't remembering a lot back then. But wait, let's go back to Flippers and Peanuts.
Yeah, right. But I feel like there was like, I'm trying to think of the 80s parties, 80s clubs. Well, sure, like Roxbury. Flippers, peanuts, Roxbury. Sounds like you didn't see each other. Well, I wasn't remembering a lot back then. But wait, let's go back to Flippers and Peanuts.|||对，没错。但我觉得好像有……我在努力回想80年代的派对、80年代的俱乐部。嗯，当然，比如罗克斯伯里（Roxbury）。Flippers、Peanuts、Roxbury。听起来你们没见过对方。好吧，我那时候记不太清了。不过等等，我们回到Flippers和Peanuts。
Yeah, Flippers was a roller skating place where... Did you know about Flippers? Flippers is now the CVS on the corner of Los Anagas and Santa Monica. And you still go there? It was like Studio 54 but roller skates. But no way! It was happening. And then there was a big club where the Beverly Center is right now.
Yeah, Flippers was a roller skating place where... Did you know about Flippers? Flippers is now the CVS on the corner of Los Anagas and Santa Monica. And you still go there? It was like Studio 54 but roller skates. But no way! It was happening. And then there was a big club where the Beverly Center is right now.|||对，Flippers是一个旱冰场，在那里……你知道Flippers吗？Flippers现在是洛斯阿纳加斯和圣莫尼卡街角的CVS药店。你现在还去那儿？它就像穿着旱冰鞋的Studio 54。不会吧！当时真的很火。然后现在比弗利中心（Beverly Center）那个地方以前有个很大的夜总会。
Oh yes! Called Odyssey, wasn't it? Odyssey, yes! Roxbury though, that was the spot. And then above the Roxy, on the rocks, that was a biggie. On the rocks. The whiskey bar at the bottom of the Sunset Marquis was a big haunt for me.
Oh yes! Called Odyssey, wasn't it? Odyssey, yes! Roxbury though, that was the spot. And then above the Roxy, on the rocks, that was a biggie. On the rocks. The whiskey bar at the bottom of the Sunset Marquis was a big haunt for me.|||哦，是的！叫奥德赛（Odyssey），对吧？奥德赛，是的！不过罗克斯伯里才是王道。然后在Roxy夜总会上面，“On the Rocks”酒吧，那个也是个大热门。On the Rocks。日落马奎斯酒店（Sunset Marquis）底部的威士忌酒吧曾是我经常光顾的地方。
Oh, that was banging, yes. Me too. Yeah, it was a good time. So see, I do remember things. But just not her. Did you go to high school? Like did you go to high school in sets? This is a great question.
Oh, that was banging, yes. Me too. Yeah, it was a good time. So see, I do remember things. But just not her. Did you go to high school? Like did you go to high school in sets? This is a great question.|||哦，那地方太棒了，是的。我也是。是的，那是一段美好的时光。所以你看，我还是记得事情的。只是不记得她了。你上过高中吗？比如说你是在片场上高中的吗？这是一个好问题。
Ish, I did not get any. Imagine a, okay, Rashida, imagine a school bus. No, no, that was eighth grade. The back of it has a bunch of massage tables.. The back of it has a bunch of massage tables. And the back has a bunch of massage bus, right? She doesn't know about the massage. You went to massage bus school. Yeah, it was called Heartlight.
Ish, I did not get any. Imagine a, okay, Rashida, imagine a school bus. No, no, that was eighth grade. The back of it has a bunch of massage tables.. The back of it has a bunch of massage tables. And the back has a bunch of massage bus, right? She doesn't know about the massage. You went to massage bus school. Yeah, it was called Heartlight.|||差不多吧，我没怎么去。想象一下……好吧，拉什达，想象一下一辆校车。不，不，那是八年级的事。车后面有一堆按摩床……车后面有一堆按摩床。车后面有一堆按摩车，对吧？她不知道按摩车的事。你上的是按摩车学校。对，它叫Heartlight。
It was an experimental school. It's just one year. Exactly. And I also grew up with Amanda. Yeah, yeah. Oh, Jason's right, Amanda. Yeah, we all go back. Yeah, yeah. Amanda, oh, Jason's right. I've known Amanda since high school, yeah. Yeah, we all go back.
It was an experimental school. It's just one year. Exactly. And I also grew up with Amanda. Yeah, yeah. Oh, Jason's right, Amanda. Yeah, we all go back. Yeah, yeah. Amanda, oh, Jason's right. I've known Amanda since high school, yeah. Yeah, we all go back.|||那是一所实验学校。只读了一年。没错。而且我和阿曼达一起长大的。对，对。哦，杰森说得对，阿曼达。是的，我们都有渊源。对，对。阿曼达，哦，杰森说得对。我从高中起就认识阿曼达了，对。是的，我们都很有渊源。
Where did the acting bug come from? Was there a... At what age? Well, your mom, obviously your mom. My mom was an actress, yeah. Was an actress for... Was she encouraging there? The great Peggy Lipton.
Where did the acting bug come from? Was there a... At what age? Well, your mom, obviously your mom. My mom was an actress, yeah. Was an actress for... Was she encouraging there? The great Peggy Lipton.|||对表演的热情是从哪里来的？有什么……在多大年龄？嗯，你妈妈，显然是你妈妈。我妈妈是一名演员，是的。曾是一名演员……她在这方面给予鼓励吗?伟大的佩吉·利普顿。
Yeah. Yes, the great Peggy Lipton. Yeah, she was encouraging. I was like, my rebellion was like, I'm not doing this Hollywood bull. I'm not doing entertainment. You've been surrounded by it, and you're right. Yeah, I wanted to be a lawyer.
Yeah. Yes, the great Peggy Lipton. Yeah, she was encouraging. I was like, my rebellion was like, I'm not doing this Hollywood bull. I'm not doing entertainment. You've been surrounded by it, and you're right. Yeah, I wanted to be a lawyer.|||是的。是的，伟大的佩吉·利普顿。是的，她很鼓励我。我当时的叛逆心理是：我才不搞好莱坞这一套胡扯呢。我不搞娱乐。你一直被它包围着，你说得对。是的，我想当一名律师。
I wanted to be taken seriously. I wanted to be legitimate. You would have been a great lawyer, by the way. Yeah, you would have been great. For real, you would have been. Thanks, Will. What kind of lawyer? I wanted to litigate. Like, I wanted to be like, you know,
I wanted to be taken seriously. I wanted to be legitimate. You would have been a great lawyer, by the way. Yeah, you would have been great. For real, you would have been. Thanks, Will. What kind of lawyer? I wanted to litigate. Like, I wanted to be like, you know,|||我想被认真对待。我想成为合法的（专业人士）。顺便说一句，你会是一个非常棒的律师。是的，你会很棒的。真的，你绝对可以。谢谢，威尔。什么类型的律师？我想打官司。就像，我想成为那种，你知道的，
Spencer Tracy in Hair at the Wind. You know, like I wanted to argue the case in court. You could do that with a lot of different kinds of law, can't you? Yeah. But there's no particular law that really interests you, like environmental law or criminal law. I probably would want to have been like, yeah, I would have been like a DA or something, you know? Rashida, with all of your success already,
Spencer Tracy in Hair at the Wind. You know, like I wanted to argue the case in court. You could do that with a lot of different kinds of law, can't you? Yeah. But there's no particular law that really interests you, like environmental law or criminal law. I probably would want to have been like, yeah, I would have been like a DA or something, you know? Rashida, with all of your success already,|||像《风中长发》里的斯派塞·特雷西那样。你知道的，我想在法庭上为案件辩论。你可以在很多不同类型的法律领域这样做，不是吗？是的。但没有什么特定的法律真正让你感兴趣，比如环境法或刑法。我大概会想成为……是的，我大概会想成为地方检察官（DA）之类的，你知道吗？拉什达，鉴于你已经取得了如此巨大的成功，
have you sort of like slowed down your dreaming? Like do you even allow yourself to, like where would you love to see yourself in five, 10, 15, 20 years? Is it more on the writing side, the acting side? Like just like harmony just with your family? Or do your goals move as often as like mine do? And do you just settle on anything?
have you sort of like slowed down your dreaming? Like do you even allow yourself to, like where would you love to see yourself in five, 10, 15, 20 years? Is it more on the writing side, the acting side? Like just like harmony just with your family? Or do your goals move as often as like mine do? And do you just settle on anything?|||你有没有放慢梦想的脚步？比如说，你是否允许自己去设想，你希望在5年、10年、15年、20年后的自己是什么样的？是更多地在编剧方面，还是表演方面？就像与家人保持和谐？还是说你的目标会像我的一样经常变动？你最终会安定下来吗？
Yeah. That, no. I don't know. I'm in a real like maybe you guys can tell me because you're a tiny bit older than me. I'm having that moment right now where I'm like, I don't know anything. I don't know anything. That's better.
Yeah. That, no. I don't know. I'm in a real like maybe you guys can tell me because you're a tiny bit older than me. I'm having that moment right now where I'm like, I don't know anything. I don't know anything. That's better.|||是的。这个，没有。我不知道。我正处于一种……也许你们可以告诉我，因为你们比我大一点点。我现在正经历那种时刻，我觉得自己什么都不知道。我什么都不知道。这样更好。
And by the way, you can do it all because you're already doing it all. I don't know, am I? I don't know, sorry. We're also like approaching. I just started therapy, this is true, I'm going to get real for a second, and I fucking don't know anything.
And by the way, you can do it all because you're already doing it all. I don't know, am I? I don't know, sorry. We're also like approaching. I just started therapy, this is true, I'm going to get real for a second, and I fucking don't know anything.|||顺便说一句，你什么都能做到，因为你本来就已经在做所有这些了。我不知道，我真的在做吗？我不知道，对不起。我们也在接近……我刚开始做心理治疗，这是真的，我要说点真心话了，我他妈的什么都不知道。
This is the most scared I've been in my life, is right now. That's good news. That's good though, Will. Wait, why? Because it's really scary, I'm doing like, I can't even believe I'm talking about this. I had heavy therapy this morning and I can't believe it.
This is the most scared I've been in my life, is right now. That's good news. That's good though, Will. Wait, why? Because it's really scary, I'm doing like, I can't even believe I'm talking about this. I had heavy therapy this morning and I can't believe it.|||这是我一生中最害怕的时刻，就是现在。那是好消息。不过这挺好的，威尔。等等，为什么？因为真的很吓人，我正在做……我甚至不敢相信我正在谈论这个。我今天早上刚做了一场强度很大的心理治疗，我简直不敢相信。
It's scaring you because you're like admitting that like you might not know as much as you're pretending to know? Yeah, that's the tip of it. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's so good. And I do think there is something at this moment, there's something sort of regenerative, and I'm sure it's coming for you, Will.
It's scaring you because you're like admitting that like you might not know as much as you're pretending to know? Yeah, that's the tip of it. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's so good. And I do think there is something at this moment, there's something sort of regenerative, and I'm sure it's coming for you, Will.|||让你害怕是因为你好像在承认，你可能并没有你假装的知道得那么多？是的，这只是冰山一角。对，对。是的，这太棒了。而且我确实认为在此时此刻，有一种类似自我重生的东西，而且我相信这也会降临到你身上，威尔。
Right now you're sort of resetting, which is incredibly scary, but most people I talk to who are 50, just turned 50, have this thing where they're like who am I there's like this full rebirth What who do I want to be for the next 50 years? We're lucky. Yeah, what does my back half look like? What's actually fulfilling? What is my ego want? Do I need to fulfill my ego? Do I need to fulfill a deeper soul purpose like so much is coming about all that shit in my therapy I talk about all that stuff. Yeah Well. I talk about all that stuff, yeah, so good. Will, I'm excited for you, this is really exciting.
Right now you're sort of resetting, which is incredibly scary, but most people I talk to who are 50, just turned 50, have this thing where they're like who am I there's like this full rebirth What who do I want to be for the next 50 years? We're lucky. Yeah, what does my back half look like? What's actually fulfilling? What is my ego want? Do I need to fulfill my ego? Do I need to fulfill a deeper soul purpose like so much is coming about all that shit in my therapy I talk about all that stuff. Yeah Well. I talk about all that stuff, yeah, so good. Will, I'm excited for you, this is really exciting.|||你现在正处于一种重置状态，这非常可怕，但大多数我聊过的50岁、刚满50岁的人都有这种感觉，他们会觉得“我是谁”，仿佛经历了一场彻底的重生，“接下来的50年我想成为谁？”我们很幸运。是的，我的下半生会是什么样的？什么才是真正充实的？我的自我（Ego）想要什么？我需要满足我的自我吗？我需要去实现更深层的灵魂使命吗？在我的心理治疗中，有很多关于这些狗屁倒灶的事，我都谈到了所有这些。是的，好吧。我谈到了所有这些，是的，太棒了。威尔，我为你感到兴奋，这真的令人兴奋。
I wouldn't be scared, I would embrace it, like embrace the fear of doing it. But the fear's good, because we're all scared. I had to put eye drops in just so that my eyes were white because I just was like, it was rough. Oh, well. I know, I had a really rough morning. Really? I love it. It's been a tough couple weeks.
I wouldn't be scared, I would embrace it, like embrace the fear of doing it. But the fear's good, because we're all scared. I had to put eye drops in just so that my eyes were white because I just was like, it was rough. Oh, well. I know, I had a really rough morning. Really? I love it. It's been a tough couple weeks.|||我不会害怕，我会拥抱它，就像拥抱那种去做的恐惧一样。但恐惧是件好事，因为我们都很害怕。我不得不滴眼药水来让眼白保持雪白，因为我当时觉得……太难熬了。好吧。我知道，我今天早上过得很艰难。真的吗？我喜欢这样。过去几周真的很艰难。
It's been a tough couple weeks. Yeah, yeah. But good for you for doing that work, because you could just like slide by and you could probably be okay and live in denial for the rest of your life and the fact that you're going deep right now means you're gonna rebuild
It's been a tough couple weeks. Yeah, yeah. But good for you for doing that work, because you could just like slide by and you could probably be okay and live in denial for the rest of the life and the fact that you're going deep right now means you're gonna rebuild|||过去几周真的很艰难。对，对。但你能去做这种心理探索真的很棒，因为你本可以就这么混过去，可能也能过得去，并在余生中一直处于否认的状态，而你现在选择深入挖掘，这意味着你将重建自我，
and be like the best version of yourself. By the way, the best part is I told Polar yesterday and she's like, oh, I'm so glad. I'm like, what do you mean you're so glad? What? She's like, oh, I'm so glad I'm like what do you mean? You're so glad She's like 20 years too late Talking about laughing about it on a podcast I think at this stage of your life
and be like the best version of yourself. By the way, the best part is I told Polar yesterday and she's like, oh, I'm so glad. I'm like, what do you mean you're so glad? What? She's like, oh, I'm so glad I'm like what do you mean? You're so glad She's like 20 years too late Talking about laughing about it on a podcast I think at this stage of your life|||成为最好的自己。顺便说一句，最棒的部分是，我昨天告诉波拉（Polar）这事，她就说：“哦，我太高兴了。”我说：“你什么意思，你很高兴？什么？”她说：“哦，我太高兴了……”我说：“你什么意思？你很高兴……”她说：“整整迟了20年。”在播客里谈论并拿这个开玩笑，我想在你人生的这个阶段，
You've done stuff like you've had like the this huge first couple chapters of your life and you have the work stuff and you have the adolescence and then the work stuff then the kid stuff and then the work with kids stuff and blah, blah, blah and you get to this point you're like, okay, now what? Right, and also that's all that stuff that you thought for your entire life was gonna fill the gap.
You've done stuff like you've had like the this huge first couple chapters of your life and you have the work stuff and you have the adolescence and then the work stuff then the kid stuff and then the work with kids stuff and blah, blah, blah and you get to this point you're like, okay, now what? Right, and also that's all that stuff that you thought for your entire life was gonna fill the gap.|||你已经经历了很多事，比如你人生最初的几个宏大章节，你有工作，你有青春期，然后是工作，然后是孩子的事，然后是带孩子的工作，等等等等，当你走到这一步时，你会想：好吧，接下来呢？对，而且这也是那些你一辈子都以为能填补内心空虚的东西。
You're like, wait, it doesn't quite fill that gap. There's still a little piece missing, and what is that piece? And we're privileged enough to have succeeded in a way. But I think for everybody, they're like, wait a second, it's just gonna be this forever? All the firsts are gone. Yeah, it's so interesting.
You're like, wait, it doesn't quite fill that gap. There's still a little piece missing, and what is that piece? And we're privileged enough to have succeeded in a way. But I think for everybody, they're like, wait a second, it's just gonna be this forever? All the firsts are gone. Yeah, it's so interesting.|||你会想：等等，它并没有完全填满那个空缺。仍然有一小块缺失了，那究竟是什么？我们足够幸运，在某种程度上取得了成功。但我认为对每个人来说，他们都会想：等一下，难道以后一直都是这样吗？所有的“第一次”都消失了。是的，太有意思了。
Wow, I talk about all that, Merchida, in my therapy. But to your point, Jason, like I think everybody here, including me, I wanna not to be overly earnest, but I wanna be able to create from like a real source, from a feeling of connection. So I'm like, I'm taking a little breath to figure out what that actually is and what that looks like and what I wanna say because, you know, I don't know,
Wow, I talk about all that, Merchida, in my therapy. But to your point, Jason, like I think everybody here, including me, I wanna not to be overly earnest, but I wanna be able to create from like a real source, from a feeling of connection. So I'm like, I'm taking a little breath to figure out what that actually is and what that looks like and what I wanna say because, you know, I don't know,|||哇，默奇达（Merchida），我在我的心理治疗中谈到了所有这些。但正如你所说，杰森，就像这里的每个人一样，包括我在内，我不想显得过于一本正经，但我希望能从一个真实的源头、从一种连接感出发来进行创作。所以我现在……我正在喘口气，想弄清楚那究竟是什么、它是什么样子的、我想表达什么，因为，你知道的，我不知道，
I don't wanna just put shit out and also it's hard to put shit out right now. All right, so Rasheeda, so then first of all, everything you're saying is so well said, that's so succinct and to the point and I love it. What is the best advice somebody's given you to get over what we're all talking about? Or to not get over it, but to kind of deal with it.
I don't wanna just put shit out and also it's hard to put shit out right now. All right, so Rasheeda, so then first of all, everything you're saying is so well said, that's so succinct and to the point and I love it. What is the best advice somebody's given you to get over what we're all talking about? Or to not get over it, but to kind of deal with it.|||我不想只是随随便便倒出一些垃圾内容，而且现在也很难产出什么好东西。好吧，拉什达，首先，你刚才说的一切都太好了，非常简明扼要、直击要害，我太喜欢了。别人给过你什么最好的建议，能帮你克服我们刚才讨论的这些？或者说不是克服，而是如何去应对它。
Yeah, manage it. Well, the thing I always go back to is my dad says, make decisions based on love and not fear, which sounds so platitudinal, but it's really not. Like when you think about it, well, like, you know what you were just saying, like I have often looked at my life and thought, let me just do this thing that I know
Yeah, manage it. Well, the thing I always go back to is my dad says, make decisions based on love and not fear, which sounds so platitudinal, but it's really not. Like when you think about it, well, like, you know what you were just saying, like I have often looked at my life and thought, let me just do this thing that I know|||对，去管理它。嗯，我总是会想起我爸爸说过的话：根据爱而不是恐惧来做决定。听起来像是陈词滥调，但真的不是。比如当你仔细想想，嗯，就像你刚才说的，我经常审视自己的生活，并想：让我做这件事吧，因为我知道
is the kind of safe way to do it. Or let me do this thing that's gonna make people love me and because I'm afraid of not being loved as opposed to like really, really loving something and believing in something and not caring. Worrying about the results. Yeah. Well, I realized that I have all these tricks,
is the kind of safe way to do it. Or let me do this thing that's gonna make people love me and because I'm afraid of not being loved as opposed to like really, really loving something and believing in something and not caring. Worrying about the results. Yeah. Well, I realized that I have all these tricks,|||这是比较安全稳妥的做法。或者让我去做那件能让别人爱我的事，因为我害怕不被爱，而不是真正地、极其热爱某事并坚信某事，从而不去在乎。去担心结果。是的。好吧，我意识到我有很多这样的把戏，
what I've come to sort of realize anyway in the last couple is that I have a lot of these tricks that I can do that help me get over things and get by, and I can get to a place of okay, and I can kind of put the things back on track, but there are patterns there. And I'm like, nothing's ever gonna really change unless I actually look at it.
what I've come to sort of realize anyway in the last couple is that I have a lot of these tricks that I can do that help me get over things and get by, and I can get to a place of okay, and I can kind of put the things back on track, but there are patterns there. And I'm like, nothing's ever gonna really change unless I actually look at it.|||不管怎样，我在过去几年里逐渐意识到的是，我有很多这样的把戏可以使用，它们能帮我度过难关、蒙混过关，让我达到一种“还行”的状态，还能把事情拉回正轨，但这里面是有模式的。然后我想，除非我真正去正视它，否则一切都不会真正改变。
I think looking at it, acknowledging it, and then I would say my greatest gift is just continuing to develop my inner life. Like something that is not connected to anybody else, creating almost like a little house inside, whether it's meditation or breath, whatever it is, nature. Yeah, that's self-sufficient, whether it's meditation or breath, whatever it is, nature. Yeah, that's self-sufficient and it's not reliant on external approval, gratification.
I think looking at it, acknowledging it, and then I would say my greatest gift is just continuing to develop my inner life. Like something that is not connected to anybody else, creating almost like a little house inside, whether it's meditation or breath, whatever it is, nature. Yeah, that's self-sufficient, whether it's meditation or breath, whatever it is, nature. Yeah, that's self-sufficient and it's not reliant on external approval, gratification.|||我认为正视它、承认它，然后我要说，我最大的天赋就是继续发展我的内心情感世界。就像某些与其他人无关的事物，在内心深处建造一个小房子一样，无论是冥想还是呼吸，无论是什么，大自然。是的，那是自给自足的，无论是冥想还是呼吸，无论是什么，大自然。是的，那是自给自足的，不依赖外部的认可和满足。
Yeah, love that. Anyway, have you seen Goonies? Yeah, good movie. Welcome back to Sean's Hot Takes. Hot Takes instead of hot cakes? Triple hot. Well, Rashida, you are real sweet to give us an hour of your day. That's so funny.
Yeah, love that. Anyway, have you seen Goonies? Yeah, good movie. Welcome back to Sean's Hot Takes. Hot Takes instead of hot cakes? Triple hot. Well, Rashida, you are real sweet to give us an hour of your day. That's so funny.|||是的，太棒了。不管怎样，你看过《七宝奇谋》吗？是的，好电影。欢迎回到肖恩的麻辣观点（Hot Takes）。是Hot Takes（热点犀利评）而不是hot cakes（热卖松饼）？超级火爆。好吧，拉什达，你太贴心了，愿意把一整小时的时间留给我们。太搞笑了。
Was that an hour? Wow. That's an hour, yeah. Look at us. They're breezy. It's a breezy little stop here. We were just getting into the meat of it, too, right? No, we were getting deep. I know we just started again. You want to take another bite, Will? No, I don't.
Was that an hour? Wow. That's an hour, yeah. Look at us. They're breezy. It's a breezy little stop here. We were just getting into the meat of it, too, right? No, we were getting deep. I know we just started again. You want to take another bite, Will? No, I don't.|||已经一个小时了吗？哇。是一个小时，对。看看我们。轻松愉快。这真是个轻松愉快的小站点。我们刚才正聊到核心部分呢，对吧？不，我们正聊得很深呢。我知道我们才刚重新开始。威尔，你想再咬一口吗？不，我不想。
Should we talk about therapy? Another bite. I really, really don't. I can't believe we talked about it at all. I love that you did. I love that you did. It's great to be vulnerable. Yeah. We always talk about that shit. It's good. It's great to be vulnerable. We always talk about that shit. It's good.
Should we talk about therapy? Another bite. I really, really don't. I can't believe we talked about it at all. I love that you did. I love that you did. It's great to be vulnerable. Yeah. We always talk about that shit. It's good. It's great to be vulnerable. We always talk about that shit. It's good.|||我们要聊心理治疗吗？再咬一口。我真的、真的不想。我简直不敢相信我们竟然谈论了这个。我很高兴你谈了。我很高兴你谈了。展现脆弱是件好事。是的。我们总是谈论那些破事。挺好的。展现脆弱是件好事。我们总是谈论那些破事。挺好的。
Rashida, we love you, I love you. I love you guys, this is so fun. Thank you for having me. And talking to me. Watch Sunny. Sunny, watch Sunny. Now Sunny, is that spelled with an O or a U? S-U-N-N-Y, it's on Apple TV Plus.
Rashida, we love you, I love you. I love you guys, this is so fun. Thank you for having me. And talking to me. Watch Sunny. Sunny, watch Sunny. Now Sunny, is that spelled with an O or a U? S-U-N-N-Y, it's on Apple TV Plus.|||拉什达，我们爱你，我爱你。我也爱你们，这太有趣了。谢谢你们邀请我来。并和我聊天。去看《晴天》（Sunny）。《晴天》，去看《晴天》。那么《Sunny》，是用O还是U拼写的？S-U-N-N-Y，在Apple TV Plus上播出。
Apple TV Plus, Sunnyny starting the incomparable, Rashida Jones. Rashida Jones. Rashida. Congratulations on that. Yeah, congratulations on everything. So much love to your family and continued success. Same, thank you guys.
Apple TV Plus, Sunnyny starting the incomparable, Rashida Jones. Rashida Jones. Rashida. Congratulations on that. Yeah, congratulations on everything. So much love to your family and continued success. Same, thank you guys.|||Apple TV Plus，《Sunny》由无可比拟的拉什达·琼斯主演。拉什达·琼斯。拉什达。恭喜你。是的，恭喜你取得的一切成就。向你的家人致以满满的爱，祝你继续成功。谢谢你们，我也是。
Love you guys. Thanks Rashida. Bye guys. Bye, see you soon. Oh well, Willie, that's almost your kind of half-wife, right? Isn't she's best friends with Amy? Yeah, I mean, I've spent a lot of time with Shida Rashida
Love you guys. Thanks Rashida. Bye guys. Bye, see you soon. Oh well, Willie, that's almost your kind of half-wife, right? Isn't she's best friends with Amy? Yeah, I mean, I've spent a lot of time with Shida Rashida|||爱你们。谢谢拉什达。大家再见。再见，回头见。哦，对了，威利，那几乎算得上是你的“半个妻子”了吧？她不是艾米（Amy）的闺蜜吗？对，我的意思是，我和希达（拉什达）花了很多时间在一起，
over the years. We've like, a lot of time. We've vacationed together many times. We've just done, she and I actually went, well, not, we asked her to go to Mike Schur's wedding. What do you call her for short? Sheeda. Sheeda?
over the years. We've like, a lot of time. We've vacationed together many times. We've just done, she and I actually went, well, not, we asked her to go to Mike Schur's wedding. What do you call her for short? Sheeda. Sheeda?|||这些年来。我们……花了很多时间。我们一起度过假很多次。我们做过……实际上我和她去过，嗯，没有，我们邀请她去参加迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）的婚礼。你平时怎么简称她？希达（Sheeda）。希达？
Yeah, Sheeda. Sheed, Sheedy. Sheeds. Yeah, Jones, Jonesy. Rashida Jones and me. RJ, ever RJ? RJ would be good. Oh, RJ's good.
Yeah, Sheeda. Sheed, Sheedy. Sheeds. Yeah, Jones, Jonesy. Rashida Jones and me. RJ, ever RJ? RJ would be good. Oh, RJ's good.|||对，希达。Sheed、Sheedy、Sheeds。对，琼斯、琼斯y。拉什达·琼斯和我。RJ，叫过RJ吗？叫RJ挺好的。哦，RJ挺好的。
RJ's pretty good. You're obsessed with the initials, Jay. Yeah, I do like it a lot. I just call you Jay. Oh, RJ's good. RJ's pretty good. You're obsessed with the initials, Jay. Yeah, I do like the initials. I just call you Jay. Yeah, she's lovely, she's so grounded. She's so, well, she's so smart and funny and just razor sharp and has always been. And yeah, I always like spending time with Rashida Jones.
RJ's pretty good. You're obsessed with the initials, Jay. Yeah, I do like it a lot. I just call you Jay. Oh, RJ's good. RJ's pretty good. You're obsessed with the initials, Jay. Yeah, I do like the initials. I just call you Jay. Yeah, she's lovely, she's so grounded. She's so, well, she's so smart and funny and just razor sharp and has always been. And yeah, I always like spending time with Rashida Jones.|||RJ挺不错的。你对缩写真执着，杰。是的，我很喜欢缩写。我都叫你杰。哦，RJ挺好的。RJ挺不错的。你对缩写真执着，杰。是的，我很喜欢缩写。我都叫你杰。是的，她很可爱，非常脚踏实地。她非常……嗯，她非常聪明、有趣，而且思维极其敏锐，一直以来都是如此。是的，我总是很喜欢和拉什达·琼斯在一起。
And easy on the eyes. And easy on the eyes. And easy on the eyes. Easy on the eyes. But she's grown up in such a potentially privileged, isolated environment, yet does not seem that at all and probably works hard to not be. Very, very down to earth. If you didn't know that her dad was Quincy Jones and that she'd grown up in Hollywood,
And easy on the eyes. And easy on the eyes. And easy on the eyes. Easy on the eyes. But she's grown up in such a potentially privileged, isolated environment, yet does not seem that at all and probably works hard to not be. Very, very down to earth. If you didn't know that her dad was Quincy Jones and that she'd grown up in Hollywood,|||而且很养眼。而且很养眼。而且很养眼。很养眼。但她成长于一个潜在的、优越且封闭的环境中，却一点也看不出那种架子，而且她可能为此付出了很多努力以避免变成那样。非常非常接地气。如果你不知道她爸爸是昆西·琼斯（Quincy Jones），也不知道她在好莱坞长大，
if you met her in a coffee shop in Kansas City, you'd be like, oh, she's just somebody from any town, USA. Yeah. And who is just a smart, you know, awesome person. But she has no, there's no, she's not spoiled to that way. No, no, yeah, really great. But at the end there, I like that we got real real about it. And I like talking about that stuff and I'm glad you're doing that well. That's really great.
if you met her in a coffee shop in Kansas City, you'd be like, oh, she's just somebody from any town, USA. Yeah. And who is just a smart, you know, awesome person. But she has no, there's no, she's not spoiled to that way. No, no, yeah, really great. But at the end there, I like that we got real real about it. And I like talking about that stuff and I'm glad you're doing that well. That's really great.|||如果你在堪萨斯城的一家咖啡馆里遇到她，你会觉得：哦，她只是美国某个普通小镇来的路人。是的。而且她只是一个聪明、你知道的、非常棒的人。但她没有……完全没有那种被宠坏的样子。没有，没有，是的，真的很棒。但在最后，我喜欢我们真正敞开心扉谈论这些。我喜欢谈论那些事，我很高兴你做得很好。真的很棒。
And I love when Jason asked if when you know, we weren't done if you wanted to take another BITE! Out of the meat. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barbeco. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
And I love when Jason asked if when you know, we weren't done if you wanted to take another BITE! Out of the meat. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 10% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barbeco. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||我特别喜欢杰森问大家还没聊完时，你是不是想再“咬”一口肉。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess是100%有机纯天然，由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗伯·阿尔马贾夫和贝内特·巴尔贝科手工匠心制作。SmartLess。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。